wow they've been great Mondays
Mondays are rough but at least we're
here to entertain right
[Music]
we're here to entertain we're here
Mondays you know it's a big day you
gotta
get yourself together
get back to work or school
you know as Gabe says F Mondays man
you guys hate Mondays
I I actually love Mondays
favorite day of the week no you don't
liar I love my job so I do that's the
answer I was looking for Dan I think
it's a fresh start you get a fresh start
on the week so I I happen to Like
Mondays there you go Zach never The
Optimist
well this guy said that they like
Mondays I said I like Mondays and you're
like [ __ ] you Dan yeah because you're
lying
you weren't sincere Dan you weren't
sincere oh my God you
Dan you changed since you got that chair
you know what yeah everyone's saying
you've changed bro I've changed I've
changed literally your your
Consciousness has been uploaded into the
into the cloud to the new sphere you
literally don't care if you live or die
at this point you know what I have to
say to that
what are you blowing fog yep
wow
[Music]
whenever Dan has wants to remove himself
delete him from the conversation he
blows a little fog and ascends
transcended
anyway guys off to some riveting
conversation here on Monday
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh Express expressvpn and Jen
lock thank you to them
last week we had quite an exciting week
of shows
you know some of the drama over spilled
over
into this fresh week here specifically
talking about
Liam versus semen
quite a quite a Clash of Titans
uh for those of you who didn't watch you
know Seaman is a man who loves feet
people like semen
my boy Seaman he's made that very clear
he loves feet and then Liam is a young
lad who you know says that Seaman
contacted him
for feet videos and a whole debate
ensued on Friday was it Friday yeah it's
Friday baby where Liam and Seaman
started arguing about somebody was lying
and then there was a mysterious third
guy Mike who was talking to Liam well
guys
at long last we have the answer we were
gonna do a full investigation
I was going to go back and look or pour
over every detail of the case connecting
the dots you know drawing the fabric
the twine yeah well Liam made a video
and he said how I trolled the H3 podcast
[Music]
and people were not happy I have to say
in fact
poor Liam
I guess he's playing with forces he
doesn't understand
[Music]
because I guess he he
well I think he erased all this so
people were so mean I I want to say
right off the bat guys we do not need to
be mean to Liam Liam gave us beautiful
content that we all loved so well we all
loved the Liam versie man debate okay
it's fantastic
and I do find it
I I mean he did an amazing job of
trolling everyone I have to admit
because nobody I didn't know that
I mean we all had our suspicions but the
way he did it was was pretty interesting
like
because the call what was so confusing
the conversation was so benign right
that he had that he faked that was an
interesting part the other part that
messed with my head is that semen
confirmed talking to him about all these
details right yeah we like to troll he
confirmed talking to him that was the
weirdest part which means you know that
means Siemens really getting into some
feet if he's just all these
conversations are blamed together dude
what is going we are getting just
absolutely spammed by shoe knives right
now oh really should we bring him on
from multiple from multiple accounts
wait let me pull up the lot the chat is
that one they're all called shoenice 22
on YouTube and I keep putting them on
time out and then another account called
the same thing spans how does he do this
shoe nice has like a an elaborate bot
system there's a botnet yeah wait can I
well I guess people watching can they
can replay the chat right yeah although
because we're removing them I don't know
if they'll show up later dude here's
another one it just keeps happening how
are you doing this show I've been
snoring drain the wall thing wait wait
how is he doing this he's got shoe nice
is employed
an elaborate botnet
how many memberships is that Chewie
right that's a good point too each one
has to be a member to do it so he's
actually giving quite a bit of money I
think
wait it says she gets you next to 200k
immediately erased so wait how many
accounts does he have a membership I
don't know that was from shoe nice 20.
we appreciate the membership though but
just just don't spam you could just do
one yeah you want do you want to talk to
a shoe you maybe you can call in I don't
think you need to spam our chat yeah we
we've had we've talked to you about
spamming our chat show wait are you sure
he's being I don't think he's being
banned is coming from the same account
how the [ __ ] is he doing 14 accounts no
way
yeah he's true Joker brain yeah you you
think you know you've seen the the movie
Unforgiven
it's like there's it centers around
Clint Eastwood is the ultimate badass
cowboy
and there's this British journalist
who's following this Cowboy and he's
like I'm following the ultimate Cowboy
I'm writing a story about it and that
cowboy got gets killed by Gene Hackman
and he's like this is the badass Cowboy
spoiler alert it's like a 100 year old
movie though
and then you know and then Gene hackmans
gets killed by [ __ ] Clint Eastwood in
a mad [ __ ] drunken rage she kills
like 20 men
and then he's like the real cowboy is
way too [ __ ] dangerous and he doesn't
want to have anything to do with me
that's shoe nice if you're you're you're
basically your Joker brain you're way
you're like Gene Hackman too
uh Clint Eastwood Clint to shoonizes
Clint Eastwood that extended analogy
makes sense he was the first man you
gotta you gotta tip your hat to that
is he still spammy yes it's still
happening the latest one was called go
ahead love
unflushed toilet
so here's another screenshot the latest
from Chewie
um on flush toilet watch shoe nice
that's it just watch shoe nice
I I'm kind of impressed he's been able
to figure out how to run an elaborate
bot system oh here comes another one
vaginal yeast infection
send me the screenshot so I can so I can
show them as they happen here's another
one Ela is a horse
dude how is he doing this so fast
what is happening how is he doing this I
don't know but thank you for all the
memberships uh sure nice you are
certainly our biggest fan I've never
seen this in our chat and somehow it's
shoe nights that's got the here's
another one
dude what the [ __ ] is a horse watch you
nice
and you're sure that all these accounts
are being banned yeah it's a different
one every time so how many is that now
uh 21. is it really 21 you've been
keeping count 22 now yep here just here
let me show them as they're happening I
guess here let me just put the chat on I
mean it's five bucks a pop he spent over
a hundred dollars so far doing this yeah
but shoe nice is he's killing it since
uh Cameo true
here let's just let's just enjoy the
chat for a minute there you go shoe nice
22. let's just all take in the madness
that is sure nice watch shoe nice
there's another one shoe nice on YouTube
it's 24. okay can somebody send me a
link to this YouTube channel that he's
doing this from well they're all
different here we go yeah I know I'm
just curious like what's the URL dude
he's like a basically an Indian uh
spammers click Farm you know what once
once they get banned I can't click on
the profile
this channel he's promoting but yeah
yeah yeah oh no not his main challenge I
don't care about that shoe please stop
spamming you can call into the show you
know your friend of the show
I mean shoot me an email I'll set you up
he has my number too so I mean oh here's
another one wait wait
here shoe nice buy a shoe nice Cameo
there you go see
this is elaborate operation here's
another one
buy a shoe nice Cameo see now now he's
thinking now he's marketing yeah there
you go this is the kill show will you
eat a tampon for me on cameo
I think he well and he said that those
days were behind him but no but he says
a lot of things oh yeah I know what
happened we banned shoe nice because he
started drinking again and we said once
you get sober you can come back on
and
um last I checked he was back on the
wagon is on the wagon is drinking or off
the wagon is drinking
off the wagon because you fall off the
wagon when you the wagon is sobriety I I
suppose yes but doesn't the wagon carry
the booze so won't you be on the wagon
well we're not all I'm on the way
wagon's carrier
I would think the wagon would be like
the drinking would be the wagon right
I'm off the wagon
I'm off the ride off the rails your feet
are on the ground
yeah I mean I can see it working that
way too but traditionally shoe nice uh
22 oh I meant how many we got here love
35
36 no way
he said shoe nice on YouTube right in
2024. bite in 20 okay A little political
message from Shoei
Biden 2024 there you have it he's a he's
a uh Pro build back better shoe nice
here ladies and gentlemen
um I love sleepy Joe I mean do you guys
remember when he left one time he on one
of the comic section was a hundred
percent of the comments he must have
left hundreds of comments from different
YouTube channels right he owned and
upvoted them all
I never seen anything like it I mean
this guy could be teaching classes on
how to manipulate YouTube okay say shout
out to our mods uh good job Ray so you
put it in work yeah shout out to the
mods for sure
anyway thank you to all of our members
by the way
uh we love our members
you know you get the Early Access you
get the especially shoe and you're not
only that
now we've got the exclusive BTS brought
to you by AV who we love so well thank
you BTS Nation happy to do it BTS Army
I'm sorry not Nation [ __ ]
now
that could be have you have you seen
anything lately love or is he out of
account oh final count is 38. okay 38.
so very impressive show definitely got
my attention
so congratulations show maybe next time
you could do a hundred
maybe you could also do the premium sub
next time if you want it's 20 bucks 30
times five is uh 190 so that's that's a
decent amount of cheddar although for
the amount of advertising it got I guess
that's a good deal dude you know how
much advertisers pay me for this much
right
that's the best deal ever that's a good
point
yeah 200 bucks is a [ __ ] steal
anyway yeah thank you guys so much to
all of our members we love so well
there'll be a new when will the next BTS
be up someone asked maybe yeah maybe why
are you slacking let me just I'm sorry
what is it people are asking when the
next BTS oh it'll be this week I started
shooting really this morning yeah you're
gonna do you're gonna try to do one a
week yeah don't kill yourself by the way
I mean the last one was super easy she
was directing me in cam this morning
pretty hardcore so there you go a one
extra video
for and don't be afraid to you know use
me if you need me for something I would
love to have you yeah yeah use me in it
use me Daddy I was distracted because I
got a message from someone on Discord
saying maybe I have a recording of shoe
nice admitting he has a hacker to spam
okay well whatever I don't have
whatever he's got I'm impressed I don't
care what who he's paying I'm impressed
I don't care
anyway back to Liam
um you know I was saying that Liam
wait is this his video that he deleted
yes this was deleted maybe we shouldn't
watch it if he didn't want it out there
I mean it's already up I think he was
just afraid of all the backlash he was
getting but I'm here to say to the world
that we need to leave we need to give
Liam a break leave me I'm allowed I mean
I don't know should I I feel like it's
fine to watch it because it was a public
video and I think he just it's already
been
re-uploaded on the subreddit and stuff
right yeah but I'm not here to blast him
I want to leave Liam alone I I my I
think Liam's hilarious I don't care if
he troll like like you said earlier it's
it was great contest he's a good guy
yeah I thought he was trolling the whole
time but yeah I thought it was good
content he was funny what can I say so I
was saying that anyway it was so
interesting and wild and he really had
me convinced that Seaman was lying to me
and he had at one point convinced that
Mike was real
like 60 of the people voted in our poll
67 billion right yeah thought Mike was
real
I'm still convinced it's Mike Mage like
man
still [ __ ] his gym starts you know
what's interesting I think the part that
really gave it away when I was watching
back because over the weekend I was
analyzing it and re-watching it back he
says okay well then who was I talking to
I was like that stick right yeah
he kept delivery though he kept trying
to drive yeah it was like a punch line
yeah
uh oh throbbing veiny dicks buy shoes
wait Chili's back yes well we gotta ride
this train all the way
this one is uh yeah throb he said what
was it called throbbing throbbing veiny
dicks okay thank you Sherry for that
star [ __ ]
so is he just making new accounts right
now or is it it seems like it would have
had to have been I'd love to hear a shoe
please just call I want to know how you
do this
you come on plug your cameo do whatever
you want here I'm gonna email him right
now just tell me how you're doing this
dude
that's right he has so many
um yeah but I think this is the main one
h3tv call in all right just please I'm
I'm you know
you want to call in to the show
no more spam just call in and talk about
it all right I just messaged him
yeah I have bat also bad news about the
pop-up
what we're thinking about canceling the
signing because
well not the pop-up but just the signing
portion because
um you know we're doing the Looney Tunes
uh
Teddy fresh pop-up which is a big thing
for us we invested a lot of money and
time it was gonna be our first pop-up
but four people next door got coveted
where there's a fourth person today what
the [ __ ] I know what's going on over
there they're all vaccinated and they're
all masked yeah
I have no idea
but we're afraid of just meeting and
hugging and especially because Ila's
pregnant
of course yeah
so that was just today another person
last week there was three today a fourth
one was reported
what the hell man
and they're all their symptoms are
relatively mild well everyone's
vaccinated so they're fine right yeah
it's it's just it's so odd I mean yeah
we had
the first three didn't really Trace back
to each other it seemed that they were
you know
separate incidents like they didn't sit
near each other we had a holiday party
that none of them attended what yeah
none of the first three were at the
Holiday party
that is very odd
I did hear that they were coughing in
each other's mouth during lunch as a
game I don't know if that has something
we do that on a daily basis in none of
us it's the cost of my mouth game baby
yeah
come here coughing my mouth then
right now come on on camera
anyway I don't know so we're worried we
need to decide today but I think we're
probably gonna cancel the signing the
pop-up will go for it but I'm very sorry
about that uh here comes from septic
foreskin how do you even think of this
[ __ ] bro
septic foreskin
blizzy blizzard Woofy what the [ __ ] is
that even mean
no that's that's our mod oh shout out
sorry bro
sorry bro wait what is this shout out
don't oh there's a gamer word yeah wait
are you serious well it doesn't actually
say it but it's a keemstar meme
uh that's a keemstar meme yeah Alex is a
stupid you know what that's that that's
the original keemstar uh you never saw
that I mean
I probably did but anyway you know what
it is I didn't commit it to me okay
should I snow racial slurs please huh
huh all right dude whatever I can't I
can't do the shoe nice show today okay
Colin or not bro I don't know what to
tell you I sent him the emails you've
got the open invitation I don't know
what you want from us
oh wait
oh no mail delivery subsystem address
not found what he that's the email he's
been emailing me from for years who also
who closes an email maybe he got banned
first spam or something that's a good
question I didn't even yeah I don't know
anyone who's ever closed I don't even
know how to close an email I'm gonna I'm
gonna text all the numbers I have for
him
okay do a mass text Shane and then let
us know oh no you got it
literally since like 2017 this is the
email that I've spoken to shoot he
locked it down and it's gone
okay that's [ __ ] interesting man
that's [ __ ] interesting
all right well anyway back to Liam if we
can please uh but to this sweet lad you
know
he came out it was gonna come out I
think he knew the the the Chokehold was
squeezing dude the scrutiny we were
gonna Figure It Out Boy
closing in on them definitely and so he
made this video he said I'm coming clean
and what I mean I don't know why people
just have to take [ __ ] so seriously I
mean semen is a good sport everyone had
fun
let's not crucify poor Liam here he's
just having fun and making content for
the show okay let's watch it's me Liam
and I thanked the whole thing
well their emails are mine the phone
number is mine the texts were faked and
I want to be clear on my intentions
before I even get started I didn't do it
for money I didn't do it for clout and I
didn't do it for a job on the podcast
hold on
this is interesting I knew this was
going to trigger on my intentions before
I even get started he didn't do it for a
job but I didn't do it for clout and I
didn't do it for a job on the podcast
course it goes without saying if one's
available I'm right here I did it just
because I was I've taken a hiring this
guy just to tell an AB
I would trigger Amy to the [ __ ] Sky
what is that what somebody Hiram yeah I
don't know some people I got a lot of
messages on Friday people got mad saying
that I always say that I don't want fans
to be hired even though I was a fan
which is not the case at all I vouch for
love Cameron and Olivia
I just think if you're calling in for a
job it's kind of ridiculous
why because I mean I think cam did it
right cam was a fan of the show he
showed you his work you were impressed
by his work yeah I mean we had a long
real long really working relationship
with Camp yeah I'm all for it but what's
wrong with calling I'm just curious I
want to just I want to just pick your
brand on this
I don't know we're trying to do a show
are you gonna it's not a Sweepstake so
you're gonna be like you know what well
I would agree with you baby and
explicitly been like are you guys hiring
right but like he did a whole bit no I'm
not talking about Liam specifically no
God Liam was funny no I'm just saying in
general what what about me and Ian we
shot emails is that wrong
now I got you in here I don't know you
guys were early you guys were before the
Og man yeah Ian's the one that started
the whole meme yeah I mean he's the
original everybody
I think every everybody who works here I
guess other than me uh
got a job by reaching out in some way
like that right like I think so at this
point which is interesting you know a
lot of people I I personally I think
that for me personally I found that
that's the best way to find good people
we've tried I mean the podcast for years
we tried working with people and you
know it never really worked out and I
found that you know
well listen what can I say you all know
the crew's amazing we love the cruise is
the best thing here so God bless God
bless I think we figured it out I try to
get the fans involved as much as I can I
vouch for three fancy moderators I took
two fans with us to the front of me
shoot when we were on the Hollywood tour
shout out Avery and Nate I love the fans
but the interesting thing though there
is a little Vindication here for Avery
because he was like
um
there's a copyrighted song at three
minutes he had this whole shtick
I and I feel like he might have been
right about that
Amy said yo when Liam called in he's
like there's a there's a song at three
minutes so just be careful and Evie's
like [ __ ] clout Goblin and we were
like why I still don't know
Goblin the clown yeah I guess yeah game
recognizes the game right so yeah I
don't know I was yeah I was beaming a
little bit just because we were throwing
out ridiculous theories and so like we I
just thought that was so stupid that I
mean it was a little odd to call it out
but I didn't really think that proved it
or anything but uh I need that clout
well you're you're thinking was on such
another plane that we didn't even
understand what you were saying yeah
anyway I know uh here's Liam bored on
the original
Asia podcast I was sick at home and just
wanted to call into the podcast
um
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] I'll just ask you uh you
need to decide if you're doing the uh
the signing at the pop-up right now
evidently
like literally right now right now live
where who's that come from uh Lena's
asking but via Ela
holy sh okay lean is here as the
pressure is on the pressure's on
Okay so
I guess we shouldn't do it you know the
thing that I guess we shouldn't because
if one of us gets covered it [ __ ]
everything up like everything up and
also he was pregnant which I don't want
to risk I just it's so [ __ ] up it's so
sad that this we wanted to be there so
bad for our first pop-up event
um
[Music]
but the signing is going to be a lot you
know with the pop-up they're only going
to let a certain amount of people in
it's it's mandatory vax it's the masks
it's good but I know if we do a signing
I think that's totally safe but the
signing everyone wants to hug you and I
and me too and shake hands and you know
that's what the whole thing is like hey
what's up dude
and so I think that's where the risk is
what do you think I'd be
I mean I don't know it's a lot of
pressure what do you guys think should I
cancel the signing or go with the I I
think you should cancel it
I would probably say just do it if ELO
wasn't pregnant that's but that factor
that's that's not worth it we were
talking this morning about it and it was
like I don't know why I didn't think
about but yeah I mean she's almost a
term and that's a complication that yeah
you don't want to miss that it's not
worth it
ah but okay I know it sucks and I'm sure
fans were very excited about it but it
will do you got to look out for the
baby's health
you don't even have to think about it
dude we'll do another signing soon we're
gonna do more pop-ups but
[ __ ] that sucks I wanted to be there and
record it and stuff
yeah a b will be there you guys can give
him covet I'm just kidding I'm gonna I'm
gonna go and help him out too so I will
I'll be there but then if you guys I was
thinking I would stop by
yeah we're always thinking this what if
we put up like a Plexiglas you know like
you see the clear glass but that could
be like corny when you go to meet
somebody in uh prison visit them that's
it
like a bubble you know I don't think
it's corny I think we could find a work
around I work in America are you serious
people taking photos of us behind
plexiglasses
automobile the hugging thing what if we
get one of those bubble things and like
you know those like arms with plastic
arms that I'd be down for you could hug
through the bubble I would 100 be down
to be a Bubble Boy we have that big
thing we put on Ian when he had covered
oh yeah wait what Among Us looking oh
yeah dude was having a panic attack
after five minutes that thing's yeah
wait is so is the bubble real the Bubble
Boy thing well is that a real invention
yeah I mean are you like the one from
the movie that I don't think so but let
me call Ela because she keeps stalking
me let me just put her on speaker
um
yeah hold on
okay
like can we get our hands on a bubble
care about showing your phone okay
you're all you're live right now so you
know
so we were just discussing like if we do
Plexiglas or
be a Bubble Boy
yeah Bubble Boy
remember Bubble Boy
yeah but I don't know if that's a real
thing I doubt that's a real thing yeah
yeah
that's the real thing plexiglass is a
real thing but it will look weird it
will look bad in all the photos I think
what is chat saying yeah so
so yeah are people gonna be
still interested in it because you can't
hug you can't really take a picture yeah
just like hey I mean it's it's weird but
I mean maybe it's better than nothing
with the Plexi people are saying here
I'm looking at the chat
uh semen semen semen semen says still
spamming how many is that left to seven
57
shoe nice is spamming our chat with
plugs with uh he's that's the 57th
Channel he spammed from
let's do a poll yeah let's do a poll
let's say plexiglass or just cancel the
signing this pop-up will still happen
yeah should we
uh because with the pop-up it's not so
much of an issue because the
the area where you get to see the
clothing and buy it is
closed and we will
keep like only a small amount of people
in there at a time
and then everything else happens
Outdoors like the food and the
activities so it's but the signing is
like another small room
yeah it's a small room and then but the
main area is really big so I'm not
worried about that people are a lot of
people are saying Safety First which I
appreciate I just hope people still go
there because we put so much effort into
it
all right
it really yeah
babe yeah you know Baby safety I think
all right I just started uh all right
here's the poll do it with plexiglass
cancel Safety First well when you put it
that way you almost have to you
hamstring them a little bit How You
Gonna vote against Safety First
80 are saying cancel it
wow because Dan basically but yeah
you're right Safety First
because then you're implying the other
option is dangerous Danger first
all right I think I think we'll have to
cancel the signing but with the promise
that once once it's safe we'll do
another one
yeah I mean I'm I'm really sad about it
but
yeah somebody suggested you guys could
just be there on lovebot
oh my God
that's kind of funny good idea actually
is that a good idea or is that the worst
I think it's kind of it's kind of
reliable in the wild in that too
yeah exactly well we could try it just
as a gag yo here's a bubble
blue bubble shield design what if you
zoom in somehow just like on a different
screen dude wait hold on can we buy this
this is the dumbest thing ever
it's a bubble Shield are you watching
this Sheila
no I'm not let me put it on
yeah bubble this is the bubble Shield
yeah this could work you know I guess we
got one of these a Halo
um
[Music]
all right well that we're going to
cancel the signing maybe we'll make a
lovebot appearance that'd be fun let's
try to do that let's try to do a love
about the anger all right you can just
kind of surprise some people
but with the promise guys I hope you all
still want to go it's gonna be so much
fun yeah
yeah when is it yeah it's this weekend
it's Saturday it's this Saturday like I
said there's going to be free food
there's going to be spray painting
there's going to be Nails you get a
preview of The Looney Tunes Club it's
going to be a ton of fun so I hope you
guys still come out for it I mean we're
not ethernet but it seems like a lot of
us will be there as well but I want you
guys to be safe too yeah you guys are
still like celebs people are going to
want to meet you guys well it's a web
like z-list but I'm saying the P not the
split hairs here but the people who are
going to be there are going to want to
meet you guys
we're gonna have to get you in a bubble
if you go right because we will be
around you guys then and then that kind
of defeats the purpose of going on I
don't want you guys to get covered
either right and that I also would not
like that all right well I'm gonna have
to figure this out anyway thank you Ela
peace and love we're gonna continue with
the show so all right love you okay
thank you so much all right are you
gonna say it back
are you going to say it back when you're
live you're embarrassing me
love you so much I miss you already
since you left home
um it's just not the same here without
you no adorbs seem really sincere
okay all right bye bye
all right anyway
this crisis averted I think
this is what h3tv is all about folks
real-time Logistics that's right that's
right all of chat heard my voice why
your voice crack I don't know why it's
doing it wrong
yeah
one day maybe when I'm like 40 I'll be
good I'm almost 30 still cracking to
back him up my voice did crack earlier
today just
it's not all in those people thank you
baby
now we're getting spanned by dicks dicks
dick dick dick dick dick dick just
calling you dude what is wrong with this
man shoe nice you you you
this is unprecedented Joker braining I
text him I haven't heard [ __ ]
so you did a group text with all five of
his numbers well I can't wait I guess I
might have deleted the other ones but
the most recent one I texted it's
nothing no no response
all right let's let's push on we got a
show to do
it's actually ad time but we've
interrupted the Liam thing like 10 times
by now so maybe let's just finish that
and we'll do that okay let's come up
with some story and so I remembered
something about Barefoot boys driving
club and I came up with a little bit of
a fake story and wrote down some texts
and uh I called in and I was reassured
that it was a good bit because the
screeners immediately put me through and
Ethan immediately selected me for a call
I the entire process from when I
actually called to when I was live on
air took like four minutes I made up
there you go guys can't give good calls
get on there true it's that simple
people
just lie to me baby yeah I was gonna say
I'll take I'll take fake calls all day
if there is entertaining as his it's
fine
um
yeah exactly the entire story and it it
actually has a pretty good reception and
Ethan was even kind of like yo you
should make more fun videos so later
that night I actually went out and made
Foot videos now I want to be clear I did
actually buy the rig for this I did
actually sink like 75 bucks into a
Barefoot boys driving rig I sent him a
hundred bucks by the way I wanted to
make him whole for the experience nice
yeah
after it went up on the podcast I
thought well that was it that's all I
really needed to do and then people
saying wow you'll get so many fake calls
now oh no that man got very right you
mean unlike what's had been happening
yeah exactly literally every call of
them but if you can fool us I mean then
just go along with the fiction if it's
funny it's funny usually not that
serious well usually we've been pretty
good at sussing out that one girl troll
well
I don't know it's funny I think it's
funny I mean you know
but like uh what can you do it's
radioactive he's having a big joke out
of it
by the way what's going on with Carlos
is anyone oh yes I think it's in the
dock wait hold on sorry Liam I gotta I
gotta cut you off there buddy
we gotta check on uh
three is it definitely just link it in
Discord yeah
it's the whole thing well there's there
was a there's a bunch there's like a
bunch of tweets
oh here it is it's actually at the top
Carlos has some wild posts on Twitter
not that I I will get to that I just
want to look if at the bids if they're
making any money
all right so far guys it looks like we
have a
oh no nine hours left
are you [ __ ] kidding me
love am I understanding this correctly
there's nine hours left on this auction
yeah that's the only one on auction and
it's nine hours left and and what's the
current bid 40 dollars
yeah something like that
should we buy it but I'm so surprised
that they listed that one first because
that's like the worst one that's he that
he kept he was adamant about doing it in
order which again I agree I was like
don't do it in order bro nobody cares
about this one
oh but some of these have standing
offers that are pretty significant like
wow there's one with a 0.3 bit yeah
that's
that's what I mean
a thousand bucks maybe yeah 1.5 yeah hey
that's this
exactly
this is awesome man
yeah so this uh exclusive could be yours
for 40 bucks
this uh unlicensed clip of a video
that basically you have no ownership of
even in terms of blockchain [ __ ] I
thought for sure their logo would have
gone for the most
that's what I thought and he never
minted it yeah that's [ __ ] all right
I'm out anyway Liam take the floor
please I'm begging you so I realized the
content farm that could be created out
of something like this and decided to
continue going at it the text message
screenshots were actually just me
texting myself wait she was gonna call
my number he doesn't have my number he's
saying if she just brought a video and
he's saying if you want me to call in
what's the number
you want me to say the number Live Well
I can't do that yeah tell them to email
me if you're watching just email me you
know my email God damn
I'll get you hooked up
if you don't know Apple iOS has a
feature where if you text yourself it
just sends you the text back so just
some simple deleting of text messages
can make it look like you're having a
conversation with anyone
the email for boys driving at
hotmail.com and barefootboysdrive at
outlook.com and every possible variation
you could ever conjure up in your little
head is owned by me I registered them a
couple days before the podcast as I was
setting this whole thing up once I had
an hour-long video of me driving
Barefoot and I had all of the proof that
I possibly needed I reached out to Zach
on Instagram to tell him that I was
ready to come on the podcast so why did
c-man say that he remembers Liam dude he
confirmed so that's it I would we would
have known this was fake yeah if he had
just been like nobody yeah but Liam was
like I remember talking to an 18 year
old I remember he wasn't taking it or
yeah Seaman said I remember talking to
18 year old I remember him not taking it
seriously I remember this right he
confirmed this whole [ __ ] story right
yeah that's what yeah
well anyway shout out Liam Liam I think
the reason why we're so conflicted is
because semen just
he confirms his story it's just the
weirdest thing
anyway uh whatever leaves leave semen or
leave Liam alone please guys
you do not he was saying people were
like messaging his some of his family
members and [ __ ] and I was like guys
stop it's not that serious why do you
have to take [ __ ] so far yeah
you know
uh some weirdo [ __ ] anyway let's do some
ads and when we come back we will talk
about Travis Scott we've done a whole
deep dive into this tragic incident such
a nightmare
so many ins and outs to so many
perspectives and I'm sure there's a lot
of details gonna be coming out every day
here
but uh we'll explain it as best as we
understand it
um
coming back after the break why are you
laughing during this very serious moment
oh because another account named [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] just uh
spam like 500 messages how many is that
love
64.
dude shoe what are you doing how is this
possible
this [ __ ] could work minimum
wage make more money the amount of time
he spends making fake accounts and stuff
well I mean if it's getting in the
cameos he's been like a thousand hours
farming fake accounts
the Duke could have a PhD by now on
astrophysics with the amount of time he
spent
all right thank you to our sponsors
today hello fresh we love them don't we
folks
hellofresh is the pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivery that comes right to your
doorstep skip the trips to the grocery
store and count on hellofresh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit let's see some of those
beautiful meals our Super Troopers have
been preparing
um
I love hellofresh damn
damn damn
oh Bill pot of soup eh you got a stupid
little stew got a stew going yeah so
here's how it works they send you a box
with dry ice in it so it stays nice and
refrigerated with all the fresh
ingredients and a really cool print out
of how to cook it about the food I've
learned a lot I mean I cook a lot I
think I'm pretty you know relatively
experienced home chef but I've learned a
lot
from cooking with
hellofresh do you have ab's burrito that
you can pull up
I think I might have deleted that off my
uh I need to do a Redemption arc on
hello fresh and cook a new thing okay I
will yeah
anyway guys I love hell fresh it's a ton
of fun
uh
hellofresh offers 50 menu and Market
items to choose from every week
including vegetarian calorie smart and
Gourmet options providing plenty
a variety
hellofresh is a can't beat in value even
at full price it's over 30 percent
cheaper than grocery stores
and this holiday it's the deal it's the
time to try to you know make even make a
little money on you save a little money
you know
um go to hellofresh.com
h3tv14 and use the code h3tv14 for up to
14 free meals
and three free gifts
that's once again hellofresh.com
h3tv14 and use the code h3tv14 for 14
free meals let's go
guys there's a reason it's America's
number one meal kit
we love it thank you hellofresh
[Music]
uh uh from peace and love to fear and
loathing
it's experts Reverend
internet service providers know every
single website you visit
and if you search stuff like
who's the most degenerate Searcher in
this office
Zach Zach
if you have a search history like Zach
the ISP can sell your information to ad
companies and Tech Giants who then use
your data to Target you
sorry that yo we could use this service
Boom the quartering
right
well what was it uh uh Forest cream pie
shout out shout outs
Exodus BBN creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so your online activity can't
be seen by anyone shout outs the
quartering
it's as easy as closing the bathroom
door
fire up the app and click one button
it's rated number one by CNET and tech
radar works on phones laptops even
routers so everyone who shares your
Wi-Fi can be protected you know
expressvpn is pretty awesome
um because
there's just so many reasons to protect
your data
um
and one of the Great
things it can do too I think we were
talking to love yeah we're like love use
your expressvpn so you can watch Doom
right because he was in Sweden and it
wasn't available and you did right yeah
I did that's awesome very good there you
go you see
love that secure your online activity by
using expressvpn.com h3tv today that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com h3tv and you can
get an extra three months for free
expressvpn.com
h3tv thank you thank you
there's a a little I know it's late but
I've managed to take it out it's Abby's
burrito there
I'm very proud of that burrito it was
really good I'm sure it was photography
skills might have been a little off yeah
such an epic photo
maybe sent that for a hell of fresh
photo to show their food
just spectacular
I'm gonna add it to my main hello Fresh
album so I just always
thank you to our final sponsor
the groundbreaking HBO series gen lock
the fate of an increasingly hostile
World rests on five soldiers who upload
their minds whoa something familiar Dan
upload their minds to Giant Mecca war
machines yeah basically you this is
actually an integration this entire uh
chair with the ad
the mind is a powerful weapon but who
really is in control executive produce
and starring Michael B Jordan season two
of this action-packed animated series is
now streaming on HBO Max dude HBO Max
freaking rules they got so much good
content there
50 years in the future a global
Extinction event ravages Earth War rages
between the union and the polity
quality
I don't know
who hold very different ideas on how to
save Humanity as territories fall the
Union's charismatic leader
preaches about a higher existence For
All Mankind the Gen Locke team is the
polit polity's greatest weapon utilizing
advanced technology they upload their
minds to weapon robotic suits to combat
the Union forces sick Bro zap our minds
into [ __ ] robot machines I uh this
sounds cool I might check this out tell
you the truth is up my alley the team of
Fighters will soon learn that digitizing
their minds can leave them more
shell-shocked than the battlefield uh-oh
as their darkest thoughts become reality
whose War are they fighting and at what
cost hmm
the heart pounding new season of gen
lock features a star-studded voice cast
including Michael B Jordan Dakota
Fanning Macy Williams
Asha Kate Dylan and David Tennant
season two of gen lock is now streaming
on HBO Max Humanity will prevail my
friends
it will and thank you so much all right
[Music]
you see the note about police say Mecca
not mechs they're different things
at the bottom I said Mecca
do you agree with that statement that
those are different things if they say
so I'm not here to so I'm not prepared
to start arguing with our sponsors I
don't want to argue with them I waited
until the ad was over we're out of the
ad this does not count as part of the ad
I'm just from this conversation Mecca
and Mech I'm not dying on this hill bro
I'm not getting involved in the mecca
Mex conversation I haven't there's
enough Strife in my life all right fair
enough Ethan speaking of HBO did you
watch curb last night no was it a good
one it was definitely better than uh
that's good yeah
no I haven't washed it yet I'll probably
watch it tonight
all right well let's talk about the I'm
hesitant to get into the serious stuff
but I know we should actually know
there's a few more things we can
go ahead with that
what's he saying
that's the sound pipe from the clip
where he fell off the stage oh [ __ ] okay
from years ago no interesting
um here's a video that I had a little
bit of a viral moment on Tick Tock guys
yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] cracked me up
hey guys you guys know who I am
all right cool well take care
hey guys yeah so I saw me and Eli were
down shopping we're just doing errands
in the Hollywood area
and you see these buses everywhere and I
was like oh I should do the rock thing
but nobody will know me
I you know I was hoping nobody would
recognize me that was the whole joke
and of course just people in the
comments who go like let's see oh this
guy Omar's my favorite one of the top
comments I guess why would you post this
Scott humbled real quick
okay I just love they start arguing he
goes That's the joke he says Nah
okay someone says you clear don't watch
H3 or know Ethan's personality
but he keeps going this guy's my
favorite
man there's too much oh wait here yeah
here he is with 1.8 million on Tick Tock
3 million on YouTube 2 million on
Instagram yeah it's safe to say he
expected someone to react
it's funny he doesn't know me he doesn't
even follow me
anyway whatever
I just think it's funny how he's so
anyway whatever whatever
but it worked out great you know I was I
was holding the phone myself
captured it's perfection
hey guys yeah it's pretty awesome you
guys know who I am
all right cool well take care dude it's
absolutely just stead silence shock yeah
I liked all the people are saying that
they were just shocked into uh
submission oh yeah they couldn't believe
it was
yeah for sure
so there you have it a little bit of a
goof for you there
also a little bit of a goof we could
probably do this on Friday but
is this a character guys characterize
you guys well somebody posted this meme
on the subreddit
mm-hmm uh who would so can I copy your
homework okay
so at the top
is the I'll help you with it is that a
dis by the way because because Ela kind
of unpacked this for me she said her
sister used to really annoy her she
would ask her for help on the homework
and she wouldn't just tell her the
answer she would be like no I have to
show you how it's done or I'm not
helping you so is that what this means
or they're just like yeah you can have
the answers well I think theoretically I
mean
you know that's the the good student
answer
well it depends on your perspective I
guess yeah that's the that's the [ __ ]
nerd answer yeah the snooty yeah the
snooty poppy with it yeah but I mean if
the objective is to like actually learn
from the homework then I suppose that
that's probably the best clearly not for
anyone
so how does Sam feel about being
characterized she said that she is
should have been in the Bold of you to
assume I did the homework section well
it's Sam my mom my mom definitely yes a
b did they Peg you here
all right
not really I'm sort of the person who
did all the homework and lied about
doing it so I don't have to share it but
oh that's for sure you know yeah wait
wait you would lie to your homies just
so that you didn't have to share it
uh if it's about school work now they go
[ __ ] themselves no I'm not I'm not
sharing that yeah yeah no interesting so
I mean I think I think that still is the
best category I think because that's the
one that's effectively like yeah I did
it but I'm not gonna let you copy but
I'll help you yeah it is correct in that
I've never missed any homework in high
school so there you go good good boy
good boy
he was Yeshua Hassan's yes sure Olivia's
yes sure
I mean that seems right Ila said that
that was accurate for her right yeah I
don't think she would care yeah
both of you do assume I did the homework
Dan Cam and love 100 correct
yeah yeah love said that he also he's
he's like me he never did homework okay
I made the prediction that Dan's a type
to never do the assignments and then
just like Ace the exams which he
basically kind of confirmed sort of
maybe not ace but not ace but
you never do the homework and then you
get an A on the final exam and they they
just barely squeak You by Cam said it's
accurate but I wouldn't say it like a
smug a Comic Book Guy
right okay sure fair enough right so do
you guess this homework count to the
final grade yes very much so oh
I mean it depends on the course doesn't
not necessarily no we have uh like tests
at the end of the year and that's what
matters I wish that that's how it worked
yeah and the vast majority of cases it's
you know it's like a weighted system the
homework might be worth like 40 of your
grade and then right the exams worth
some percentage
I don't want to think about homework
that much I'm so glad I don't have to
think about homework it is
a part of life that you just kind of
leave behind and that's a wonderful
thing my dad's the only dick on here
basically lull nope I guess you would be
in that category it'd be it sounds like
yeah I guess maybe that is more accurate
you're the little nope guy no because I
want to say no but I'll be like yeah
yeah as soon as I finish it and you will
just lie about it yeah that's
interesting I don't I don't mess around
when it came to my schoolwork I got
those foreign parents they're very
strict about it so I'd be too scared
that they would get caught and I
wouldn't get caught cheating
I get my ass whooped
Ethan we had homework and Zach I mean
that's pretty that's definitely happened
to me I wasn't I don't know I was a
pretty good student in high school
are these accurate to is this
specifically high school or is it just
homework in general
you know does it specify at the top
that's I don't think we need to dig too
deep into the logistics of this I would
say I'm not that would not be my
category whatsoever I've never been one
of the procrastinate really so yeah so
where would you fit on this I'd fit the
yeah sure okay like I mean even my work
here I get it done right away like okay
interesting yeah it just gives me a good
boy it gives me anxiety to like think
like oh my God I have something due so
I'd rather like I would go home and just
do my homework right away
good boy sex really fast it's just like
control C control V and he's done
thank you and then the quick the best
the most accurate one obviously is Ian
where he just leaves you on read
how does that how does that is that
accurate Ian
um
I wouldn't have read receipts on it
would say delivered no you rookie
on a higher plane of existence yeah yeah
you can turn that off on your phone yeah
no way yeah you're exposing yourself
with that on that's some Boomer [ __ ]
right there Ethan wait you all have
because I have it off on like Twitter I
don't know I don't know I've never okay
you gotta talk to me after the show in I
gotta turn that [ __ ] off well you're new
to higher yeah exactly I've never had an
iPhone before
I'm pretty fun though someone said Ian's
is the most accurate
all right
I'm procrastinating right now uh getting
to the Travis Scott stuff
oh okay we have a few more top of the
show stuff Carlos dude Carlos been going
crazy on Twitter bro did anyone reach
out to him to expand on this
uh
no I haven't yet we got to get him to
call in on Friday
I I can try
I I have a feeling Carlos might be done
with us after that well you know you
never know
I think he might have enough
self-awareness to realize that that
didn't go too well
I mean but I'll try don't be quick to
judge they have a 45 bid on their newest
true coin thank you true true
someone says does your life does your
wife believe in you yet he said she's no
longer my wife
I also discovered that I love don't do
the accent yeah I know I felt that that
missed
as I did it we're just thinking sound
bites that's why it's tough does my wife
don't believe in me
and he says she's no longer my wife I
also discovered that I love bisexual
women
I was like is that is that a genre bro
like I mean
I I am presently having a relationship
with four gorgeous bisexual women
I'm very happy and satisfied with it I'm
sure you are dude Carlos just like a
[ __ ] fuzz he's got a harem bro
thank God things work out this way my
relationship with them is so exciting
never boring
sounds great brother
that explains maybe the club he was at
which is shirtless people just partying
looked like a
yeah I don't know well if I it looked I
don't I I it looked to me like he was at
a gay club and that doesn't support it
by this if I had to guess just based on
the whole aesthetic but
uh this powerful understanding is what
one needs to create an amazing
relationship that will last for years
and years to come what having a harem
it can apply to a relationship of only
two people or more the maximum number of
effectively apply this powerful
understanding is 13.
this motherfucker's plotting a 13 way
can be any combination of men and women
it is called a mastermind oh no he's
starting a cold
foreign
my goal is to have a mastermind sometime
in the future of 6 to 12 women and me oh
my God Carlos
he wants a cult do you think like when
he's in the act like he's just he's
super vibrant and being the character he
is I mean he says he's an amazing lover
so I believe it
like when he's blown his load do you
think he goes no no no no
or is it more of the uh
oh
[Applause]
yeah that's what he sounds that's his
own face yep
that was one full sound bite I think he
was looping it I was looping some it's
pretty long but yeah that's the sound
and it's just like holding a fire hose
busting his nut
s oh wow there's more oh my God Carlos
why you like your own post my guy
because I if I don't like or love myself
who will I I I'm with that there I like
that I like my own post too
I don't know you know we're planning the
three-day getaway no
the bird we are planning a Carlos Matos
58th wait he's 58.
it's in good shape okay you know what
holy [ __ ] he is incredible shape and
like his body you could tell at the club
he's well defined like he is in really
good shape when he took his shirt off
yeah we saw that uh about a hundred
times
Carlos Matos 58th birthday crypto meme
party is an all-inclusive resort in
Punta Cana Punta
[Laughter]
oh Dominican Republic for a limited
number of guests which we promised you
is going to be even sicker who is doing
this what the hell
what it's gonna it's like Hedonism that
hotel that's just like [ __ ] that zone
what looks nice Carlos Matos 50th
birthday really nice well hold on you
want to go were they planning on
getting a huge windfall or something and
then planning this orgy and Dominican
Republic because right now they're only
got 45 dollars well when did he tweet it
November 1st
ah yeah
I think they thought they were going to
make millions of dollars
right now they're at 45. so yeah I think
the all-inclusive trip is we'll have to
wait
what a shame no men allowed though by
the sound of it
no he said men and women can be part of
his Harem no no no he's hit of a harem
but his goal is to have a mastermind in
the future of 6 to 12 women and me his
Harem is all women bisexual women only
by the way okay
you have to want to have sex with my
other
wives
do you think the other crypto Bros would
attend oh yeah
they need their own Mastermind though
dude that's wild man
sure nice is still going and the latest
one says uh Ethan Klein owes shoe nice
twenty thousand dollars okay come
explain to me what are you aware I I
have seen some reports in here that I
guess he said he uploaded a video and in
it he said that he doesn't have my email
I don't I mean shoot we've like me he's
uploading videos show me that [ __ ]
make me that all right I sent the first
one okay okay shoot you tell us you're
I'm not gonna say a phone number live
you understand that that's not happening
so if you're smart enough to figure out
how to run a botnet right you're smart
enough to figure out how to email us bro
next video is
I don't have your phone number Daniel
he's uploading videos just I don't have
your phone number I know you don't have
my phone number but you have to I know
you have my email because we've we've
shoe nice 22 correspondence for years
hold the phone this is high level
content I don't have your email Daniel
Ed sheer wonders why people aren't
watching his videos well my email my
email is public I don't have your emails
I just remembered them as just type in
indeed and seeing Daniel bro you got to
tell me your email it's damn done alive
it's not me bro I swear to God damn you
but he's saying it's not him yeah so I'm
saying it's not me bro
no it's not I know your behavior the
um he's sitting in a car somewhere
though he's not in a Mainframe he's
slamming Cameo I'm live it's not maybe
it's somebody trolling him but I think
it might be can we just please
appreciate that he's uploading videos to
his main Channel
as a way to communicate with us I mean
yeah it's kind of fantastic he would
hate emails all the time so that's like
the biggest [ __ ] look he's got
something happened to his Yahoo account
so I guess that does make sense he can't
he can't log in and and just have it
autocomplete well hold on guys hold on
well let's see what's going on in show
because he did I don't have your email
Daniel he uploaded another one tell
Ethan to say his numbers
everybody tell Ethan's chat I don't have
his number they blocked me in comments I
have no control of that dude let's talk
either way he was trolling me for years
that guys
you're a nice fan he's trying to get me
to 200k post your number tell me your
number my email is gone because my email
was sent to all these gay websites by
haters he did get blocked his email got
shut down for spam
for spamming gay websites that people he
might have been saying that people
signed him up it's just I don't believe
that he's got all these dedicated haters
oh [ __ ] I just I mean I could be wrong
by the way 20 minutes earlier shoenice
was slamming two McRibs in one minute so
hey everyone shoe night again
from internet AJ rise and fall the shoe
nice hopefully he got the story right
the others before him didn't all right
guys I'm going further let's go to the
chase issue the world records 58 seconds
a minute and two seconds going for 58.
on your mark game face hurts and get set
in my face
[ __ ] cops
shoe nice so this was just 10 minutes
before his videos
to us
so he was he was doing this while um
while the spam was going on so that does
support his theory that it uh well why
but
I'm just so confused by the shoe nice
Network
I love how we're becoming the mystery
gang of the internet trying to solve all
these conspiracies well this is just
weird I mean it's a it is a very deep
mystery to me
it kind of makes sense because these
comments that has been posted is kind of
like for shiny like with the team store
stuff
but why would somebody be so dedicated
to spending so much money and saying buy
shoe nice cameos you know um whoever the
you are I want to talk to you not sure
nice I want to talk to the bot guy no I
don't want to talk to shoe anymore
sure I don't know what to tell you bro
it's not that [ __ ] hard just email us
email Dan what are you saying he doesn't
have my email my email is Dan at
h3h3productions.com it's public you can
you can email me you can even bro come
on rip yeah rip your email rip my dog I
mean we've said it on the show a million
times before yeah it's not hidden okay
Dan unless you're shoe nice or the
hacker this the bot
as a public email yo Dan maybe it's the
chair like it's involved into its own do
you think the chair itself set up the
botnet yeah okay well according to love
we have 77 shoe night spams 77
membership shoe nice bands like who
would spend that money who I mean that
that you know we're looking at like 400
385 dollars is innocent I'm with Chewie
I kind of believe this who would do this
I mean if someone wanted troll you who
else is a better person to pretend to be
too nice
well shoenice has a history of this
though because that's right no he left a
thousand comments bro on one of our
videos It's gotta be him it's It's gotta
be it's shoe nice there's no he could be
paying someone to do it right
I have my suspicions done I just don't
understand why someone would it's not a
troll they're promoting his [ __ ] they're
saying subscribe to Shoon eyes and go to
his cameo
right
I mean they do seem to be supporting him
but maybe the hope is to get him in
trouble for botting he's already banned
from everything for spam always on
YouTube
oh he still got his YouTube channel no
that doesn't make sense to me
all right once we get into this Travis
Scott thing we have to see it through so
we got to put on our blinders here
you all ready for this
can we watch that video at least if
we're gonna maybe we should start off by
it
because you're going to come out of this
not being you're going to be coming out
of this hating Travis Scott
and what better way to set it up and
then to watch his dumbass falling off
stage while singing auto-tune
[Music]
wait I didn't see it it like froze for
me
am I crazy or is it freezing it's
freezing it's freezing [ __ ] cruising
right at the critical moment too oh what
it's got seven million views
and it just freezes here
so weird the [ __ ]
YouTube's [ __ ] flipping it's not
flipping I mean it's not freezing for me
oh here I change the quality
[Music]
it's such a beautiful fall yeah
such a Serene fall
so actually we're gonna talk about it
and we actually have people lined up
here
um who were there who have some stuff to
share so
anyway
um let's talk about Travis Scott then
we'll get to some calls
yeah so I'm sure many of you guys heard
there was a huge news everyone's been
talking about it Travis Scott
has a music festival called Astro World
this is the second one they've done Ian
or is this like a ongoing annual thing I
think it's the second yeah that's what I
heard
um
so this is the second astrophest I think
there was about 50 000 tickets sold
and well what happened was you know
there was what's called crowd Crush
when everybody looks like this is the
third actually the third 2018 2019 the
2021 got canceled because of covid and
then this year so yeah there's a crowd
surgeon I mean
I feel like I've experienced that on a
smaller level I don't know if that's
just common to festivals where you just
kind of get tossed around in the
currents of people yeah I've been in a
few very scary situations that shows uh
similar to what happened here but
obviously you know it subsided before
anybody got seriously hurt like on this
one but yeah it can be really scary I I
had a small taste of it where it's just
like you're basically completely
helpless and you know it is scary and
then you're like oh my God this is
actually dangerous just standing here
when you have that realization yeah
what happened in your case was it was
the performer say something I mean there
was something like that
um probably the scariest one was I was
once at a show and it was like sort of a
mosh pit type situation but but too many
people for like what you would normally
think of a mosh pit where people are
kind of bouncing around and stuff so
everybody was kind of like crushed
together like you were just describing
and then
everybody was like kind of getting
rocked back and forth and then
like dominoes a huge amount of people
including me fell over and like I had
like multiple people on top of me and
like nobody could get up and thankfully
like everybody saw what was happening
and like helped each other out and
pulled each other up but it you know it
was like 300 people all like dominoes
knocking each other over and when you're
in the middle of it I mean there's
literally nothing you can do I mean it's
like thousands of pounds of force
pressing back on you it's very scary
Yeah so basically there was a major
crowd surge eight people died uh were
smashed to death
so you can imagine how intense the force
was where people were just passing out
suffocating
getting trampled on
um that's that's insane I I don't know
has there been a concert or Festival
where that many people have passed
uh not that I've heard of I mean there's
other very famous
um there were trampling incidents at
sporting events and such and religious
uh
um events but as far as a concert this
might be the worst who uh the who had
something called Who concert disaster
where 11 people oh [ __ ] oh wow there you
go what happened there something similar
uh Rush of concert goers outside the
coliseum's entry doors result in the
deaths of 11 people being trampled
yeah so this is stuff that's dangerous
we forget like I mean when you Pacos a
lot of people and together like that I
mean this is very dangerous stuff you
have to respect it and a lot of
performers do respect it which we'll get
into there's lots of great videos of
performers being like everybody stop
everybody take a step back everybody
help this person up and the really
disturbing part or one of the disturbing
Parts about this is just Travis Scott's
callous disregard for human life
human uh human safety of his own fans
yeah so eight people were crushed to
death
one of them as young as 14 my goodness
which is another interesting thing when
I first heard that I was like who the
[ __ ] would bring a 14 year old to
AstroWorld but the concert was built as
safe for all ages you know they said
bring them bring them bring your kids
uh eight people died
dozens more I heard like 300 were
hospitalized
or at least at least treated for
injuries none maybe not necessarily
hospitalized but but yeah I mean that's
a lot of people to get hurt
um there's a lot of mystery still about
like if there was a reason for the surge
or if it was just too many people
uh but here let's let's look at all the
key factors we have
you guys let's look at the apology which
first of all a lot of people have been
lampooning
um
I've seen a lot I just want to send out
prayers to the
to the ones that was lost last night
we're actually working right now to
identify the families
so we can help assist them through this
tough time
you know my fans my fans like my fans
really mean the world to me and I always
just really want to leave them with a
positive experience and anytime I can
make out you know anything that's going
on you know you know I stopped the show
and
you know help them get the help they
need you know
um
I could just never imagine it's a really
a situation
we've been working closely
we've been working closely with everyone
to just try to get to the bottom of this
city of Houston HPD Fire Department
you know everyone uh you know help us
help us figure this out so if you if you
have any information
um you know please just contact your
local authorities
um Everybody continue to just keep your
prayers I mean I'm I'm honestly just
devastated and I could never imagine
anything like this just happening
I'm gonna do everything I can to keep
you guys updated
all right so this is him after the event
so let's let's look at how he was during
the event we can kind of uh see I know
this is a this is a minor thing but why
is it black and white
that's how you know he means it bro more
emotional that's a good point why you
got to put the filter on it bro like he
made a conscious decision to put that
filter on this I don't
I really don't know what to make of that
that's bizarre like why is it black and
white by the way just an update NPR says
25 people were transported to the
hospital with 13 still hospitalized
including five miners
uh so anyway
Kylie by the way she still has the story
of Kylie his wife
his wife or girlfriend married right
Kylie Jenner still has her IG story of
AstroWorld up but deleted the posts of
the ambulance in the crowd
I'm not saying it's her fault but
clearly you're aware of the tragic
events that took place and you haven't
addressed at Norris Travis
[Music]
yeah so
there was one she took here with the
ambulance desperately trying to get to
somebody and nobody letting him through
Travis not saying anything and then she
just erased this story that's [ __ ]
gnarly
so she kept everything up about that I
mean dude that's so crazy
these people are psycho I don't know
what to say I mean it's just like so
psychotic
oh they're not married but she's the ma
the baby mama got it
so
um
here's basically you know
according to the current reports
people were passing out and even dying
and the show kept going on that was the
problem he kept playing he kept bringing
people out nobody was stopping the show
people were begging to stop the show at
one point there's even this clip here
two people go up on the stage and
they're trying to tell the cameraman who
you know he has the director there
people are screaming from the crowd stop
the show watch this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here let me mute it watching it claimed
for this [ __ ]
yeah I mean you do have to hear their
voices kind of you get the idea they're
screaming stop the show somebody's dead
I mean okay what do we think about this
cameraman I mean on one hand he's just
doing his [ __ ] job he's just a cog in
the machine but he I mean they have I
think what it what it tells me is that
he obviously could talk to everybody
from his intercom yes but he's talking
to the director I think they must know
they must know I'm sure he was like Hey
kids are here saying someone dead they
have to know
how can they not know yeah
also there's a point here where you can
hear Travis tell them who's saying stop
the show right
I'm pretty sure you can hear him say
that
[Music]
what a hellish moment for these poor
kids
it's like what do you what can you do
you know
stop the show there's people [ __ ]
dead they're like dude
[Music]
props to these guys anyway for trying to
yeah do something about it they actually
had the right idea if this guy
I mean I don't know maybe he did
like I I do worry that people are gonna
like go after that uh I mean I figure
out who that guy is in the bathroom or
something also people are saying which
is a good point he has headphones on
there's a good chance he can't even hear
what they're saying
uh yeah I mean it's possible I mean
those are gnarly headphones there's a
point where like where she walks on
stage and it seems like that's when he
realizes someone's there and kind of
jumps a little bit but yeah it's true a
lot of those calm systems are noise
canceling uh so you can actually hear uh
I don't think he could hear her I think
he's just saying get the [ __ ] out of
here you know what I mean oh apparently
the girl in that video said that the
cameraman helped someone suddenly shot
so he helped away thank you yes
apparently he helped I don't know
exactly what yeah perhaps once he
realized the gravity of the situation
because you know it's just a short video
clip there I do think like of all the
people to blame this cameraman is not
like sure right yeah let's not blame the
cameraman you know what I'm saying
um but I don't I'm sure they knew Travis
heard them he I think I'm pretty sure he
responded who's saying stop the show
am I wrong I remember hearing that on
this clip that would be pretty bad no he
definitely said that one clip
[Music]
I definitely heard that one of the clips
okay whatever it's not in this clip yeah
yeah
so
yes sad that's [ __ ] up for these poor
kids and I mean obviously everybody
there and the people that died but
okay Tick Tock let's not do that right
now whatever that is
you got the one where he's saying yeah I
swear Travis he he's so [ __ ] because
yeah I think so he he you can basically
you he cannot deny he didn't know
reasonably know
[Music]
okay one more guys
[Applause]
yes there this here's the guy saying yo
someone's dying someone's dead someone's
dying stop the show he said who asked me
to stop
who asked me to stop
here's then he starts doing this thing
where he goes who asked me to stop two
hands up this part's crazy
[Music]
put two hands up you all know what you
came to do and then watch he goes you go
listen to this oh this is a whole nother
thing after he says you all know what to
do he says I want to hear the floor
shake he's telling everyone to jump up
and down which you know there's people
on the ground people are being trampled
I mean that could have directly
contributed to people dying
we're going to look at everything in
more detail here
um
do we have a shoe nice update uh love
this is the um
message from the girl from the video
with the cameraman explicitly saying
hello please thank you do not send death
threats to anyone do not send death
threats to the cameraman or his family
please send humanity and forgiveness
please do not seek to destroy not yet I
mean obviously people like [ __ ] hell
the cameraman is not the problem here he
don't [ __ ] with the cameraman guys
direct your your anger in the right
place
Travis Scott basically
and potentially Live Nation
which is the we'll get to we're gonna
we're gonna examine this from all sides
but yeah as soon as I continue to
subscribe by the way just as a side note
uh last 79 we're at 79.
no new videos
29
so this is all just different angles yet
I think you guys do you have a good
angle of when he goes uh
when he tells people to stomp after that
if I have it on my phone here I probably
liked it
I was thinking of sending I don't know
why I didn't I mean maybe here it is
can you imagine yeah here
I'm gonna send it to you real fast maybe
you put in my Discord
yeah my whole timeline's just full with
Travis Scott's stuff was here when was
your whole for you Paige just yes that
was very bizarre oh I was liking them
all and sharing them all you just damn
what does Dan just sent Amy's burrito I
copy pasted The Tick Tock link but it
didn't copy for some reason so there you
go all right so here this this video
that this girl posted on Tick Tock shows
it really well here
so this is really interesting because we
saw it from that other kid's angle he
was screaming somebody's dad stopped the
show
maybe you're okay all these people are
being stepped up you can actually hear
him yelling I I
peace and love to the girl I'm trying to
listen to the audio in the background
trampled
suffocated
you hear it stop you think okay maybe
I'm okay
he shoes these people away he doesn't
want to hear about it yeah so the people
you shoot away we just saw was the
people saying somebody's dead stop the
show right and he's like no no no you
know what you came here to do
you're okay
[Applause]
make the ground under those feet and he
says let's make the ground shake do you
know how [ __ ] scary that would be he
obviously is in control and he does not
give a [ __ ] I don't want to hear your
[ __ ] saying he couldn't have done
anything that is [ __ ] he knew that
he was ignoring people he knew that
people were so yeah that was really bad
that could have been a really actually
really bad moment for people obviously
possibly a lethal moment for people I
mean if there's people on the ground you
don't want to start jumping
um here's another one another angle that
makes denying a denial plausible
deniability almost impossible for Travis
at this moment
so here's someone being resuscitated you
can't really see it so I'm happy about
that I don't really want to show
anything like that but here Scott
literally watching him oh well
isn't there a shot where he's looking
right there's a a very similar video of
him up on that stupid Tower
yeah this is the one where he's doing
the fortnite emote wait is he really no
okay I was like no way
yeah someone said he's like uh
it's like a bad whatever
he's doing a emote on uh on a on a Kill
that's what the comments kept saying
which I know is a very dark joke but
where's the one where he's basically
looking right at them
I'll look for it yeah look for that one
and then here's one again during the
same Festival where Travis he does this
thing by the way and this is part of the
reason why Travis is especially [ __ ]
because he has a history
of encouraging dangerous activity at his
shows a dude he encouraged to jump from
a balcony he put the actually we might
have a clip of it um
can you put that one where he tells the
guy to jump
yes so there's an event where
he's encouraging people to jump from a
balcony and actually someone who did
jump on his encouragement I'll show you
this clip when the guys find it
got freaking paralyzed at hospital broke
his legs and Spine and was paralyzed for
life
that's [ __ ] awful and he suit and
Trav and then another incident Travis
was arrested for inciting a riot at his
own show
uh and another incident where he stopped
the show because someone stole his shoe
and he encouraged everyone in his
audience to beat the [ __ ] out of him
you guys have that one right
boy
anyway here's this one
so notice everyone's screaming help stop
the show help and you think you might be
stopping to listen to them but he's
actually focusing on a guy climbing a
tree putting the light on him and trying
to get him to jump
um
[Music]
can you imagine it's like it's just what
a [ __ ] up scene bro
help stop and he's like yo look at this
dude in the tree jump
it's funny I mean it's weird there's
like all these satanic [ __ ] rumors going
on about him
I mean
it's like
the satanic names
yeah those are in there I also in the
Discord is the video of him with the fan
yeah so I don't know if this is
particular the guy who got paralyzed uh
uh because he's done this a few times
but watch this [ __ ]
this is a man who cares about the safety
of the people in the audience right
instead of being like Yo dude you need
to chill out and [ __ ] get up
amazing
I mean it seems like he's on something
clearly this dude is bugging that's so
unsafe apparently there's a bunch of
these
yeah no I think this is something he
does at his show he encourages people to
do dangerous [ __ ] like jumping off a
massive balcony
oh what about the people below him too
let's not let's not forget it
[Music]
to lower it until uh he starts talking
to him
um
I think here's another video
because God tells fan to jump off
balcony here it is
I see you what are you gonna do it
what the [ __ ] what is wrong with you
[Applause]
They're Gonna Catch You yeah right I'm
[Applause]
yes so I don't know if this is the guy
who got paralyzed they stay there but I
don't I don't think they know that for
sure
but the point of it being oh yeah
someone said I was there this person was
not paralyzed this dude actually made it
but yeah the point is is that he
encouraged people to do this when one
fan jumped and was paralyzed [ __ ]
paralyzed
you know
um so this is the type of behavior
here he is
um he was sued for that
Travis Scott reportedly sued by
paralyzed fan who fell from New York
City concert balcony
this is an article from 2017 okay Travis
Scott has become known for creating a
raucus environment at his concerts but
things went too far during the bird's
eye view tour stop in New York City
the April 30th concert saw Kyle green
who claims he was allegedly
pushed off a balcony
suffered significant injuries that left
him paralyzed from the fall
the 23 year old alleges he was pushed
off by surging crowds
huh
Travis Scott was yelling at his security
guards to bring me on stage they didn't
put a backboard or neck brace on me or
anything they kind of just lifted me up
and pulled me around then dropped me on
stage
lovely
whoa that's crazy
I fell and hit the floor before I knew
it I was surrounded by security guards
that scoop me up
um
was there any other ones oh can you guys
find the one where he's standing on the
Tower looking directly at the
the medics
here's a video of someone talking about
their experience there
it just felt like we was like literally
like in [ __ ] hell bro like it felt
like we was in a concert in hell you
couldn't breathe you couldn't see like
just imagine all the people they gonna
find tonight who was in that crowd who
nobody could see who nobody could hear
who passed out and everybody was just
crumbling on top of them the whole
[ __ ] concert like I'm thinking it's
probably gonna be like at least 100
people who dance tonight like I kid you
not like
in the VIP section it was so many bodies
laid out people was getting pulled out
who was fainted and as people were
trying to Medicine trying to give them
CPR and they was flipping them over and
like they was literally turning black
and blue like I never seen no I never
seen death in my [ __ ] life bro just
by me alone it was probably like
10 [ __ ] people laid out dead and like
once the Medics tried to help them they
wasn't responding they moved to the next
person it was nothing they could have do
like this [ __ ] like this [ __ ] really
[ __ ] me up and like really spooked me
tonight like that was like some demonic
[ __ ] and what was so crazy like people
were screaming help trying to tell
Scrabble Travis Scott it was like hell
the whole crowd was gonna help help he
just kept going bro it was like this
[ __ ] was scary bro it was so demonic bro
and mind you y'all see the type of music
I make y'all see everything like you
know like I've been so heavily
influenced by Travis But like after
tonight bro like God really showed me
like you know like stay away from that
[ __ ] bro like that [ __ ] not for you
cause like he sacrificed so many
people's lives tonight like for real
like so many people lives no not for
real
but
tonight but it is
um also the video that you've been
asking for I found it um you can clearly
see a dead body in it so I don't think
we could show it oh you can yep
oh [ __ ] well basic is this the one you
linked down here Abby
no that looks like the same angle I
don't know if that version I found the
actual video and what he's looking at is
a body being carried out the one I sent
Cuts right before the body
yeah right okay I didn't realize that
one was so graphic yeah he's what he's
basically looking right at it that's the
part it's like dude you're looking at it
yep it's like a limp body and he's like
dancing and singing I don't know why
what is this you said I can't open it
it's just a video file it's like a house
how am I supposed to watch it it's
really it really isn't much there and
people are dying
well if I'm gonna watch it I might as
well
I'm don't
there's there's nothing of value to be
seen from that video is what I'm trying
to say
the only part that's relevant is the
fact that he's looking at the body and
we can't show that this video doesn't
have the body in it okay then it's just
a video of him just standing there yeah
okay um the point is that you send a
send it and a way that I can use the
video
thank you
um
here's a really other weird thing is
like there's ambulances in the crowd
trying to get to people he can clearly
see it I mean we saw from Kylie's uh
story
which she deleted by the way
so [ __ ] that they saw the ambulance
[Music]
yeah so at one point
so at one point he did acknowledge the
ambulance but he never told people to
move out of the way and he certainly
didn't stop the show but the point is
that they knew there was stuff stuff
going on right
that clearly the directors and producers
and stuff
here he notices someone passed out and
directs security to help
oh
somebody passed out right here
somebody passed out right here hold on
don't touch him don't touch him
everybody just back up
security somebody help jump in real
quick keep going just keep it this way
somebody jump in come on come on
security get in there let's get in there
let's get in there let's get in there
let's get in there yeah so I mean
I don't know what to make of that on one
hand he did try to help one person
he kept the show going but I don't know
I mean everyone's screaming people are
dying
you know
here's really [ __ ] up this is one that
disturbs a lot of people as the
ambulance is trying to get through
people start jumping on the [ __ ] on
the yeah it's awesome
I mean in a horrible way yeah here's
people just on top of the ambulance
partying out
you you'd think he would have he would
have told people to move out of the way
the ambulance I mean there's no
communication there
I don't get it
what what I don't understand is this man
is one of the biggest
musicians on the planet
and he's done countless shows
so you think he would know how
to use the term crowd control
but he doesn't and it's almost like he's
enjoying it
yeah there's times where it does seem
like he enjoys the chaos and the Ruckus
yeah not to get all conspiracy theory
but I mean rule number one is control
your [ __ ] crowd you know he saw
everything
yeah I see a lot of people saying that
it's hard to see from the stage but
that's [ __ ] you can see everything
you can see everything yeah you can see
everything going on there
but there's directors there's producers
there's people everyone's on the mic
everybody knows what's happening also
you know the it was too many people in
it because uh people started stampeding
through the gate
this is the VIP entrance apparently so
shouts out can you put the audio on
look at this [ __ ]
these are just people rushing in who I
guess don't have tickets
who shows I mean this made people show
up to an event without tickets hoping to
get in
I've seen this happen on so many
festivals this is like extremely common
I'm surprised that
people without tickets just show up
ready to mob
yep no I have personally witnessed
fences get torn down and rushes of
people going in like many many times
security guard just one security guard
yeah just what do you think he's gonna
do
I wouldn't even try bro just at that
point okay here come the police on
Horseback good luck with that
what are you guys gonna do here
oh my God yeah you can see at one point
during The Surge maybe you guys can find
the video this security guard is just
[ __ ] people up for no reason now
that's a lot of people man you know
especially when you're dealing with an
already close to oversold show
um it's not good and these people are
all pretty wild too these aren't
necessarily the kind of people you want
pushing and shoving
this many people Dan this is normal like
thousands of people
I mean this is a particularly bad one
but yeah I mean I I've I've witnessed
this exact thing happen many times yeah
there's one I think it where they maybe
you guys can find it where the gate
Falls and people are getting smashed yep
this is it okay here we go we found it
[Music]
look at this is I think on a different
entrance
look how many people start charging
through here
and then the gate collapses on people
and people start getting stampeded it's
like such
it's a [ __ ] show I mean this is this
event is just a dangerous
[ __ ] psychology all this for some I
mean
it's not that serious to me I don't know
call me crazy I guess maybe I'm not
young enough to get it
it just doesn't seem that serious
this is a lot of people though is this a
failure of security Dan or is this just
something you assume just to organize
yeah I mean well no I mean you assume
it's going to happen but in the sense so
you prepare for it and yeah I mean this
is definitely a failure on the part of
the organizers which again like
everybody's ready to pin this all on
Travis which I do think he I mean it's
his Festival so obviously
um you know he has some culpability but
you know the event promoters obviously
are in [ __ ] too
um I mean at least depend I've been
hearing all kinds of reports of you know
maybe Live Nation
when they uh uh heard about this from
the police told them to shut it down and
they refused to in which case that would
alleviate some of the blame from them
but um
but yeah
it's Travis's event as he owns the event
it's his name it's his event well yeah
but you know how these deals are I mean
it it I'm sure he doesn't own a hundred
percent it's in Partnership
this is another spot no freaking way
dude that's like evidently he encourages
this
um which again is
that's what he was arrested for he was
telling people to break through right so
when he got arrested for inciting a riot
at his own show look how many people are
charging through here man
that's like a thousand people easy
it's just not that serious I don't know
if to tell these people
foreign
yeah so the interesting thing that's
coming out about it now is that so
obviously there's plenty of clips of
Travis Scott callously kind of ignoring
the public safety
but a new wait is that really you
is Elitch in the chat
Fila may have just super chatted I don't
know if it's the real did you just pay
yourself ELO
except they sent their thoughts in
prayers so everyone is fine now
but Ela literally said that yeah how
much Super Chat did she drop me five
dollars and 55 cents
Cheapo
yeah you'll put a note to leave a
special thanks from her uh yeah
she said oh yeah she said a special [ __ ]
you from me to both of them Travis and
Kylie for sending their thoughts and
prayers wow Eva
strong opinions today you're mad you're
mad you know what pissed me off uh
I think I I sent in the chat at one
point but um
I think there were at least a couple
articles the one that I saw was uh
People Magazine made a tweet that was
like oh pull that Kylie Jenner is okay
like they said Kylie and the preg and
her unborn daughter okay it's like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] there's eight
people dead you [ __ ]
and she was storing it already do any of
those eight people have a net worth of a
billion dollars because
who gives a [ __ ]
I gotta show it I gotta show it yeah but
what the interesting Wrinkle in all of
this is that it's now being reported
that
it was reported a mass casualty event by
the police they knew the fire department
everybody knew
they have the authority to shut down an
event if it's unsafe or for any reason I
mean they're they're in charge of the
Public's safety
and the police decided to let the show
continue for another 40 minutes after it
was named a mass casualty event wait the
police did yeah they decided not to
start stop it because they were afraid
that stopping it early would cause riots
so the police made a conscious decision
to let the event go on another 40
minutes after they knew it was a mass
casualty event once again the police are
[ __ ] I don't know it just seems like
psychotic or I mean incompetence to me
like I mean dude is that confirmed
confirmed I think so I think it is
confirmed at this point okay I mean fact
check it but
until it gets hot in Texas
right
what the [ __ ] is that
did you not find the people there I'm
looking for it right now it was in our
chat so I'm just going through our uh
pics real quick
here it is I just found it
yeah so people tweeted this out pregnant
Kylie Jenner uninjured after Travis
Scott AstroWorld incident leaves eight
dead
um I don't think the subject I think the
subjects probably should be about the
eighth and the lead a little bit there
yeah
so you make Kylie Jenner the one from
the safety of her VIP box casually
filming an ambulance uh trying to get
through the audience she was actually
safely on stage
and then deleted covered it up and left
the other ones up
okay good I'm glad she's uninjured
what the [ __ ] is that
I mean that's just crazy yeah they
deleted it after I mean everybody was
like you guys are look at the quote
tweets yeah I know 8 200 quote tweets
one thousand likes that's bad news
that's real bad that's a ratio at hard
bruh
foreign
yeah our culture is so sick dude thank
God Kylie's okay
let all the people die just don't let
Kylie get it to Kylie
she's pregnant she can't be seeing these
disturbing images
could affect the baby right I don't want
I don't want your joke to get unnoticed
[ __ ] the People magazine that was
actually really funny
oh thank you Zach
does anyone else want to uh I did
actually miss that so thanks for uh
co-sign my joke thanks for it was
bringing that back up it's quite
humorous oh thank you so much Zach
you're so funny
he's so he's so cool he's so cool
um here's more videos of people jumping
on the you know ambulance which I guess
is just cool it's just part of the
culture of his
can you pull up a story about his arrest
baby
when for inciting a riot I want to give
all the details on that
he had some muted uh but look at these
[ __ ] guys I mean dude
I'm sorry but
somebody's got to say something like you
guys need to move get off the ambulance
make way
I don't I don't think I've ever seen an
ambulance trying to cruise up somewhere
to get someone in the middle of the show
I mean this seems like pretty
extraordinary circumstance
I don't think that's normal to see
Travis Scott fans injured and Stampede
at rappers AstroWorld now guys this is
from 2019.
so like you think that he would have
learned something it was only a mere two
years ago
wait this happened at another Astro
World two years ago
yep
Travis Scott was arrested
by Chicago Police Saturday night after a
rapper encouraged attendees to climb
over security barricades and storm the
stage
the Houston rappers Festival performance
lasted just five minutes before being
shut down after dozens of fans joined
Scotland stage so they shut this one
down
that was that Lollapalooza these are all
different incidents like all these
things that Ian just sent
oh these are all different headlines
yeah okay it gives you an impression of
uh the uh pattern okay so Scott was Tara
Scott's fans injured and stampeded at
AstroWorld 2019 and then another
incident in a lot of palooza he was
arrested for encouraging attendees to
climb over security barricade and
stormed the stage another incident
separate incident rapper producer Travis
Scott was arrested Saturday night after
his concert in Arkansas police say Scott
who's real blah blah blah was arrested
after he encouraged fans to rush the
stage by bypass security protocols these
are all separate incidents another
separate incident Rogers PD issued a
statement saying Travis Scott encouraged
people to rush the stage at a show
bypassing security protocols in the
process several people were injured
including a security guard and a cop
that's crazy these are all separate
incidents
yeah so he has been promoting and
encouraging dangerous behavior and now
all of a sudden eight people dying he's
like oh my God I'm so sad I'm so sad who
could have seen this coming
yo can you put on AstroWorld
for real we got a little [ __ ] milk
boys sound bite involved that makes
sense I mean this full sun moment so I
mean killing it killing eight of your
fans at a show you know what is a real
full sound I think Travis Scott gets
full sender of the year for this yeah
absolutely
he'll be on the nelka podcast yeah he's
gonna need to be collaborating bro that
was such a full sent tell me about it
death is the ultimate sense as I said
yeah the final son the full sun to hell
yeah exactly send him to his maker boys
that's a full send
oh wow
I sent in the chat a statement by one of
the bodyguards you remember that when he
was like I was trying to stop him and he
was yelling at me calling me a [ __ ] and
stuff and encouraging people to oh the
one from that Reddit right yeah if you
could show oh that's from the arrest
Travis Scott read it no it's uh maybe
it's it's [ __ ] Travis Scott
yeah let me pull that up actually and
just look at that there's the actual
most most tragic thing to come out of
this entire event no you guys know what
is People magazine gonna think about
this fortnite pulls the Travis Scott
emote after AstroWorld concert tragedy
no oh you guys I guess there won't be a
second round of the Cactus Jack meal
either at McDonald's no I need a Cactus
Jack too with extra extra ice I forgot
about that Holy Cactus Jack that was
that was long ago
you know what's funny though to me I
mean I don't follow Travis Scott but he
has a history of doing this at every
show and people love him we love him we
put him at Fortnight we do the
McDonald's we keep giving him shows
y'all this was I've plain to see that it
was coming yeah and so the moment it's
like oh well obviously this man who
we've all promoted and endorsed and
encouraged now does the same thing he's
been doing for years and eight people
die and then all of a sudden it's like
oh well we you know I mean what the [ __ ]
guys
years ago here's a post from this uh
[ __ ] Travis Scott subreddit
years ago I was a security
card for Travis Scott concert I was at
the front of the stage between him and
the barricade this is actually on the
Kanye subreddit I'm I'm just now
noticing
this is what happened
during the show some kid tried jumping
over the barricade to get to the stage I
was the biggest guard on staff so it was
my job to restrain him and push him back
into the crowd that was my job that's
what I was being paid to do when I did
this Travis Scott called me and the rest
of security [ __ ] ass n words to our
[ __ ] faces he came to the edge of the
stage to curse us out for doing our jobs
to Roaring Applause he then said
security can't stop you well and then
directly encourage everyone to jump the
barricade and Rush the stage absolute
[ __ ] chaos ensued as we struggled to
hold them all back while he continued to
insult us and reward the people who
broke through Travis Scott nearly killed
me and my co-workers that night he
nearly killed seven several of his own
fans I remember him I remember being so
angry and so afraid and all the while
just kept yelling [ __ ] you to me every
time I successfully held somebody back
it was a horrible experience Travis
Scott doesn't care about the people who
who risk injury to make his show safe he
doesn't care about the fans who risked
their lives in the the front row of the
show Travis Scott only cares about
Travis Scott [ __ ] Travis Scott that's
all I have to say yeah and you know that
lines up with what we've seen so
I totally believe it
I mean he's trying to be rock star
create Havoc so cool people die he's
such a rebel yeah that's why he has
that's why he does sponsor deals with
McDonald's and uh epic games known
Outsiders
I'm assuming that's why he does it right
he thinks it's badass right why are you
encouraging everyone to get hurt punk
rock man I mean he's got punk rock is
his sacrificial satanic Vibe thing to
him but it's a bunch of [ __ ] it's
very rebellious to uh
to have a billionaire girlfriend and
make uh product deals with McDonald's
and fortnite very very encounter culture
yep absolutely
um somebody says never trust someone
with two first names amen
so true a lot of people have been doing
this uh blocking Travis Scott on Spotify
as a means of protest which is pretty
interesting
you know I wonder if that'll actually
have any effect
probably not but you know it's better to
do what you can the way you can do it
I'm gonna block them from uh
getting any revenue and then here's
another story we haven't even touched on
this guy Shane Morris is Travis Scott's
former manager who was left for dead in
a basement by Scott
this was actually a big store like I'm
telling you there's no depth to this
guy's Travis Scott is the worst person I
worked with in my entire career in music
eight people are dead and hundreds more
injured after Travis Scott's callous
Reckless Behavior at AstroWorld and I
hate to be the one saying this but I saw
this coming and I tried to tell everyone
yeah the story that DDOT is telling is
true I'm Travis Scott's former manager
let me probably read that Travis Scott
the same dude who left his former
manager for dead while there he was
having a seizure in the studio I for one
am shocked
oh the [ __ ] audio stopped when you
first sent this I thought this was Tom
Segura I was just about to make a
comment that this looks like and I'm the
one yeah it's pretty amazing the
likeness
it's Tom with a grill right
manager I'm the one who had a seizure
and I'm the one that he left for dead in
a basement in Los Angeles
I originally told my account in 2013 and
then it recirculated on Reddit about six
years ago the story is coming out of
AstroWorld and all the videos
documenting the evidence are quite clear
and they align with what I know about
Travis Scott when he sees people in harm
or danger he tends to only continue
thinking about himself and to make it
worse he's been doing this for years at
other concerts I could go on and on
about the theft of sessions assaults and
all the lies that he's told in his
career but the thing that I want you to
understand most is this can you find the
article about what actually happened to
this guy
um what is the story with this former
manager he left for dead
when I was looking at it yesterday it
said um
that he has epilepsy and he occasionally
has seizures and he just bailed on him
yeah and he started to have a seizure
what is that Travis Scott
here's the whole thing Cloud Bots to
artificially and oh here's at other
concerts I could go on and on about the
theft of sessions assaults and all the
lies that he's told in his career but
the thing that I want you to understand
most is that I think it's time to spill
a little tea as the kids on the internet
say and I don't mind doing this because
Travis Scott is genuinely a horrible
person so in 2009 when I met Travis
Scott I was running a site called
earmilk.com with my friends Trey and
Blake uh and I was a junior level
software engineer and I just finished
working for Myspace music so I worked in
the technology side of music for Travis
what we did was fake his popularity I
programmed a fleet of SoundCloud Bots to
artificially inflate his play counts on
Soundcloud this told record label
Executives that he was much more popular
than he actually was we also did the
same thing early on with Twitter you may
have noticed and somebody made a joke
about it that his early followers could
make an omelet because they were all
eggs
but I'm
um well plenty people like his music now
so I guess
it worked uh
yes so that's the story the guy was
having an epileptic seizure and the crew
just left in there I mean that I mean
what the [ __ ] that's that's what's
beyond
yo what's with this guy let's get out of
here we're weirdo
here's one other clip finally you know
the one time Travis Scott did stop a
show what was the reason
wait is this the one uh Ian
go down this one
so he jumps in the crowd
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah all the music
so
you can all right hang on
get that [ __ ] get him
can you imagine telling that too I'm
trying to take my shoe so he stopped he
did someone try to take his shoe to a
horde of people a mob uh to get him I
mean what the hell I mean that's got to
be a crime
to tell them all the people to beat
someone up
inciting violence
[Applause]
that's horrible
he's throwing punches
get him out of here get him out of here
[Applause]
dude I hope you I wish you had that same
energy for five eight of your fans dying
as you much as you care he spits on him
who does that
everybody in the chat saying it was a
kid too
was it really he's a minor no way look
he spits on him bro like I'm sorry dude
but
this man is demented
was it really a mile
[Applause]
I did maybe therapy I don't know
anger management Maybe
[Applause]
yeah so that's how you stop want to stop
a show grab a shoe uh dying doesn't rise
to the occasion
wait was this Travis Scott who did the
Batman thing
uh uh Ian is this him or is this someone
else uh that's him yeah Halloween I
think you really let us down Batman
this is such a [ __ ] funny photo
if only he yeah if only he was there
when we needed him
just as a no I'm not saying that that
guy was a minor
could try to steal his shoe he didn't
look that young in the video but
oh [ __ ] that was wrong about something
Olivia said no he posted that photo of
him as Batman and people started
clowning him and he deleted his whole
Instagram
come on that photo's awesome bro don't
be so don't be so soft
you left me in a black hole of rage and
confusion
so
um
there's another report which is really
bizarre
I think we watched all these videos here
that somebody this is being reported by
TMZ but I'm still not sure if this has
been confirmed a source connected to
AstroWorld told TMZ someone in the crowd
went crazy and began injecting people
with some sort of drug
The Hollywood Reporter said police are
looking into a drug spiking incident
in an area of the festival where the
chaos first began the source said it
appears to have been targeted at Unknown
People and the crowd surge may have been
resulted from people panicking and
running for safety
um oh the guy was 17 you found out the
guy he was spitting on yeah I'm reading
at 17. so technically he wasn't mine I'm
sorry bud so yeah I was right and you
made me call out chat I'm sorry I'm
sorry Dan sorry to the 17th I apologize
to chat sorry to my parents
to Satan
sorry it's a Lucifer
so basically this is a really weird
claim so apparently someone was walking
around with a needle
and was stabbing people with narcotics
and the story is that the when the pan
uh the Medics arrived they gave Narcan
to this person which is given to people
suspected of overdosing on opioids and
that worked that revived him
now has this been confirmed I mean this
is being reported by TMZ it just sounds
so outlandish I believe I'm gonna go out
on a limb here I I don't know anything
for sure but that sounds like
total [ __ ] that sounds like one of
these urban legends yes I mean people
getting spiked at shows and with needles
and stuff it is something that I've been
hearing since I was a kid
it's a total urban legend
it could have happened in this one
incident but I feel like that why would
people waste their drugs just to like
attack someone yeah and I mean you can
just inject air in someone if you want
to [ __ ] them up
honestly
people are saying police confirmed it no
they confirmed that they got a report of
it that is different than it being
confirmed that it happened well I saw a
conference where he was talking about it
let's watch that and see if we can if we
can everybody saying please confirmed it
go watch what he actually said well
let's do that we'll do it now
let's get to the bottom of this whole
thing
because it is odd it is a urban legend
at the Press briefing Fenner addressed
the claim directly saying one of the
narratives was that some individual was
injecting other people with drugs while
it remains unclear if that is the case
authorities do have a report of a
security officer who was reaching over
to restrain or grab a citizen and felt a
prick in his neck that's it
that's all that's all it says right
that's nothing
but there that actually is a huge
misinformation thing because people are
saying that it's confirmed I think it's
important to clear that up because
that's a huge
but I know there's a video if you guys
can find it I saw the cop giving a press
conference
when the officer was examined he went
unconscious and Medics administered
Narcan
finner said
Narcan is used when people are suspected
of undergoing an opioid overdose he was
revived and the medical staff did notice
a prick that was similar to a perk you
again if someone was trying to inject
you thinner stated later at the press
conference authorities revealed that
Narcan had been administered several
times at the concert authorities did not
provide an exact number of doses
specific times or the circumstance of
the doses were given here let's watch
the con this is very interesting
so
there it is was that some individual was
injecting other people with drugs we do
have a report of a security officer
according to the medical staff that was
out and treated him last night that he
was reaching over to restrain or grab a
citizen and he felt the prick in his
neck
when he was examined he went unconscious
they administered Narcan
he was revived
and the medical staff did notice a prick
that was similar to a prick that you
would get if somebody's trying to inject
that is one
part of it
the other thing that's very important
there were some individuals that were
trampled and we want to be respectful of
that but we just asked that y'all give
us time to do a product so that's okay
so one thing I think we can take away
from this is that I don't think this
incident
as described is what caused The Surge
right it seems like it was a subtle
thing that happened to this one security
guard but it sounds like there it sounds
really interesting the way he described
it right I mean it sounds like it may
have actually happened it may have
happened
but it's far from confirmed I would say
yeah again he says they he confirms that
there's a report of this no no no no
that is
he confirmed more of that the Medics
confirmed that they gave him the Narcan
and he was revived right and that they
saw a prick right
so it could be a coincidence you know
that uh it's very very odd very odd very
very odd
very [ __ ] odd
oh can you guys um
something else I was thinking about
oh about the police that it was it was
claimed a mass casualty event and then
he continued playing for 37 minutes I
want to get the facts straight on that
one
oh wait here it is I've got it
so why didn't the concert stop right
away here's where the timeline comes a
little tricky
can you time stamp this if he talks
about it there
said the police department saw attendees
going down
at 9 30 pm
fire officials said the initial
initiated a mashed casualty incident
at 9 30 pm
finners said police officials
immediately told concert organizers
about the escalating problems proof
that they knew what the [ __ ] was going
on okay there people knew
the concert was canceled 40 minutes
later that's what's so weird about this
so they saw people dying at 9 30.
they told the organizers at 9 30 that
there was an escalating problem of
people uh dying
that's what mass casualty means
and it took 40 minutes
before they canceled the show actually
he finished his whole [ __ ] set Travis
appears to keep playing till the end of
a 75-minute set at 10 15. so I mean
there's plenty of blame to go around
here the police department could have
ended it
Travis's uh
management could have ended it Travis
could have ended it when he saw I mean
everybody [ __ ] up this was just
blame all around I would say the
organizers Travis and the police could
have all stopped it and they all knew
about it that's what's so disturbing and
weird
you know
I mean
he played for another 45 minutes after
it was reported mass casualty
that's crazy that's [ __ ] insane
um you got okay
yeah I don't know what to make of that
I mean you'd think the police would stop
it no
and then Live Nation is the
so it was Live Nation and Travis Scott
together that organized the event
um
yeah Live Nation is huge I mean they're
one of the biggest touring companies in
the world yep
they said heartbroken are you the
biggest
it is the biggest yeah probably I mean
they do everything
yeah they and they refunded everybody I
wondered that and just like it's not
really that important I mean it is but I
was like so did I keep the money
you know after eight people died
how nice
yeah they refunded everyone that'd be
kind of a weird date of profit from yeah
canceled the second show
um now there's already being lawsuits
filed by the way that that happened
pretty much one day
yeah
Texas Attorney on behalf of 23 year old
um
it's just one of the girls that passed
Christian parodies
Christina Christian filed one of the
first lawsuits against Travis Scott
and Aubrey Drake Graham Live Nation and
the stadium for negligence
parodies is now seeking one million
dollars for bodily injury some of which
he claims are permanent as well okay so
this person didn't die
I don't know how you can get a lawsuit I
mean I've I've been involved in a lot of
legal stuff so I'm just surprised people
can get lawsuits together that fast one
day boom
second lawsuit's already been filed
attorney Kurt Arnold of Arnold on are
filed a second lawsuit on behalf of
Patrick stennis
he was also trampled crushed and lost
consciousness
the lawsuit accuses alive Nation Travis
Scott and others of failing to properly
plan design manage operate and staff and
supervise the event
yeah oh this person Christian
parodies is suing Drake as well
kind of funny
uh the other person is
oh I'm sorry you're talking about the
same okay that was a different lawsuit
well there was a moment where Drake came
out maybe you can pull that up and then
the audience started going crazy
I don't think I don't think you could
blame Drake for any of that I don't
think Drake knew [ __ ]
should we hold Drake accountable Ian
what do you think should we lock up
Drake let's just [ __ ] lock up Drake
unrelated
houston-based Law Firm has filed civil
lawsuits on behalf of 23 Festival
victims how do they how do they do this
so fast
they've contacted 20 civilians chasing
lawyers maybe yeah I mean it's it's
right on that yeah we've already filed a
class action with 27 people it's been
like one day all are seeking at least a
million damages due to the sustained
serious and permanent injuries they
receive yeah I mean these are all people
who are injured the real the real
damning stuff is going to come from the
families of those that passed which are
all on the way I'm sure
I think maybe why Drake was mentioned
um I mean there's got to be no doubt he
saw what was going on I mean Jake I mean
just to be fair to Drake he came out for
like one song I'm pretty sure right and
just he I don't think I don't think you
can blame Drake for anything well no no
but I mean I mean oh
yo Drake had this post up and uh who I
don't know who who was who's cam just
sent that but somebody was following
this where Drake had a post-up like even
as late as last night he had a post like
this like you know that show was lit and
he had it up for like since yesterday so
they wouldn't have been telling that
foreign
what do you know
oh Cam's grabbing the post
so here's the three here's the moment
yeah here's the moment where he brings
out drag
but this is already when people are
asking them to stop so it's another
situation of like yeah this is probably
uh
you know could have contributed to some
fatalities here
oh I don't know what's going on it's too
far away
oh a sicko mode
yeah his whole set was less than 10
minutes with Drake so
Zach wants to lock up Drake what were
you saying
I don't I don't think let's do it [ __ ]
it I I just I just think you you this
[ __ ] was going on the whole [ __ ] set
how do you not see that well it's super
loud super energetic Scott or uh Travis
is the one that heard people saying
there's people dying in between sets and
[ __ ] yeah this is the post that was
deleted I think probably even this
morning hit her up hit her hit her oh
[ __ ] I gotta okay reset Ethan
hit up ER tell him to do the ER for sure
how'd I do on that
it's great it's fantastic
little tasteful fire this is [ __ ]
fire little tape yeah he finally deleted
it today so shout out to Drake I think
he was filtering comments too like he He
Turned comments off or something like
that I always say he I mean Drake or his
Drake doesn't run us management whatever
yeah exactly
he always has that on
that filter oh he does yeah
his chat his comments be looking like uh
Ryan Kavanaugh's that's what I was
thinking too
top of the tops to be honest all of
these people do that to an extent I mean
I'm sure a good chunk of it is organic
but oh he only has 86 comments I'm down
with that I don't need I don't you know
86 comments 2.3 it's just man just a
throws the whole Cruise it's the homies
yeah
so
um
but yeah let's lock up Drake [ __ ] it we
got another opportunity
disband the Live Nation
dissolve Live Nation lock up Travis
Scott let's lock up Kylie too I've
actually known Ticketmaster right they
do yeah that's a good thing [ __ ]
abolished Live Nation it's a monopoly
dude nationalize that [ __ ] actually I
don't want to end so basically you know
um
shut down fortnite Cam said that's a
good idea yeah shut down fortnite too
close McDonald's I mean it's tainted so
actually we have calls with people that
were there sorry I came in keeping you
guys on hold for so long
we have Marco was in the front of the
crowd watching people start dropping has
some details about what he witnessed so
let's talk to Marco thanks for waiting
um
Marco hi thanks for calling
hi hello how are you
uh I'm doing a little bit better
physically
yeah
so
are have you been feeling like
fatigued or physically and emotionally I
mean what what's been going through your
mind lately
yeah
a lot of the stress and mentally
physically I had to go to the doctor
last night to get checked out just my
peace of mind
because I had a lot of pressure like on
my body from waking up that next morning
after everything that had happened
but you felt so that you were your body
was actually sore from being compressed
in the crowd physically yeah
so how how where were you in the crowd
basically you were up near the front
right in the front right in the middle
of the main pit where everyone started
uh
dropping
wow right okay so tell me so basically
tell me I guess just take me from the
beginning kind of from the show like
what was the energy like from the
beginning of the show
let's just start from the very beginning
when you showed up how was the energy
vibes
honestly probably about like maybe an
hour before Travis Scott was actually
supposed to come out it was already
completely jam-packed waiting right
there in front of the stage
there was no room to move Left Right
forward back nowhere just completely
pressed at that point where everyone
there was completely stuck
so that's still an hour out to when he
has to come out
okay so there's this like kind of rumor
that it was a surge from this crazy guy
with needles but it sounds like it was
packed from the very beginning which was
kind of a recipe for disaster
from the get-go it was like that and it
only got worse as the show started so
from the beginning you think there were
just too many people there
definitely uh I was looking at the
picture overview of the setup for the
venue and it it looks like a death box
for the amount of people that were
wanting to be there right in front of
the stage
so at what point did you I know you said
from the beginning it was super packed
um but at what point did you start to
get worried about like it might be a
dangerous situation
uh they put a counter up for 30 minutes
so when he was supposed to come out
maybe around the one minute Mark I
physically couldn't breathe and I was
already focusing on just trying to
survive
wow so even before you came out and and
it hasn't started yet and was there a
sense of panic in the audience there
well other people kind of worried about
the situation
yeah people next to me already like uh
freaking out trying to get out my
friend's girlfriend was starting to
panic so we kind of tried to get her out
but by then we couldn't make it to the
edge within a minute misery Panic
already and she was within everyone that
was there
and he hadn't even come out yet
and were was there I'm just was there
were people calling 9-1-1 I saw videos
of people in the mob calling 9-1-1
telling trying to tell the police that
it's not safe trying to get a hold of
the staff was that kind of thing going
on
yeah I saw that myself I ended up I
wasn't I started in the front and as
soon as he came out within maybe a
minute it was not even the first song I
finished I was already one person back
from the very back gate
so I've already moved all the way to the
back and that at that point people were
starting to pass out people are yelling
and like it's
it's a mass panic and
at that point we have people in a circle
just surrounding bodies trying to help
them and people waving their arms trying
to flag down people yelling to stop
their show but we were already so far in
the back and no workers could even have
seen us
so
do you think it's possible that Travis
didn't see anything or that that they
didn't know what was going on
we had workers right behind us on where
that camera was where that girl was
trying to flag down the cameraman yeah I
was right in front of there and the
people that were there didn't pay no
mind to us and we were maybe 15 feet
away from them
so I I feel it would be really hard for
Travis to be able to see my area of the
people that were panicking and calling
for help
and was there just kind of a uh was the
whole group United and just screaming
for help and stuff I mean how could they
not hear you I don't understand
especially if you're that close to the
stage
we felt drowned out the music was loud
and there was the people all around us
that were yelling as well and just
sharing with
I watched this the live stream back and
it just drowns out like it's supposed to
happen
but in that like when you're there it's
it felt like absolute hell
and well okay there was this one moment
in the show that stuck out when that we
we highlighted on Tick Tock where he's
like
he actually when those people managed to
get on stage and they say yo somebody's
somebody's diet debt like you got to
stop the show and then he's like who
told me to stop y'all knew why you're
here and then he goes we want you to
start you know I want to hear feel the
ground shake do you remember that moment
uh yeah I do I think there was it was
kind of like uh
it was misconstrued because I remember
he said uh two hands up
he kept repeating two hands up when that
kind of it made it more people panic
because a lot of people already had
their hands up trying to wave down oh
[ __ ] people right so
yeah that made it worse it kind of it
further more drowned out the people that
were trying to get help
man that's
that's just awful yeah I'm sorry that uh
you went through all that that's just so
[ __ ] up to go to a show
and have something so terrible happen
when you're supposed to be having fun
yeah it was a it's a pretty
unexpected traumatizing moment to have
to go through
so as the show kind of continued you're
like from the very beginning
you know everybody's already panicking
before he came out what was that what
was it like as it played out because he
finished he did his whole set right I
mean that's what we just read he started
that yeah he completely finished so what
was it like through the duration of the
show up until the end when like uh well
let's just say you know as the show came
to a close was it uh were you just
fighting to survive the whole time I
mean were you guys just I'm just curious
how it ended I guess
with myself I got out at 9 15 out of the
pit and I took off running to get as far
away as I could to just catch my breath
and that 15 minute span
I
it snapped in me that like I can die
right here
and I became I lost my group so I had no
one with me and that I in that snap
instant
because I had already felt myself uh
getting tired my arms felt heavy I was
starting to feel sleepy and I couldn't
like get a full deep breath
in that instant where I felt like I can
die right here I was able to get through
I don't know how they were to get
through the thousands of people that
were all lined out to the side I was
able to push my way out I checked my
phone and it was only been 15 minutes
into his set so I don't understand how
anybody could have lasted the whole hour
45. whoa that's that is insane man
that's crazy so at that point did you
just leave once you kind of gathered
yourself
I gathered myself and I went to the
medical Booth trying to find my groups
hoping not to find them there
just trying to recompose myself and
try to find my people
well
I'm glad you're okay I mean I know a lot
of people weren't but I'm glad you're
okay man and what a [ __ ] up situation
to find yourself in but thanks for
sharing your story with us you know at
that point I think it is it's all it's
important for uh posterity like you know
to make sure this kind of thing doesn't
happen again so I think it's it's it's
it's good that you're talking about it
even though I'm sure it's not easy
definitely thank you for letting me
share my story
thank you Marco you'd uh you take care
all right
thank you you too
Marco wow I actually feel really [ __ ]
sad
listening to that I was just uh
nightmarish
yeah it sounds like there's just too
many people I think it's too convenient
to blame some psycho with the needle
yeah the guy said that it was people
were being you know crushed since before
he even came on
here's another caller Eileen was in The
View let's let's talk to Eileen Eileen
hi Eileen thanks for uh sticking on hold
for us how are you
yes so so what was your experience at
the Astro World
um I feel really bad because compared to
Marco's story I actually had a really
great time so hearing everyone's stories
was like me and my my stepbrother and
all our friends we have like Survivor
skill because of that
did you see any evidence of
something wrong I mean you went there
you had fun you left everything was
great no problem
no problem at all sorry I'm leaving my
building so
when we were there we got VIP sections
so there's a separate VIP section for
uh compared to the General Admissions so
we were on the main stage of Travis's
and we were on the right side so we got
there an hour early and waited in line
for like in the pit for like an hour
plus and
was he was doing the whole hour was the
music it's a thing called fear frequency
so
it's like used in uh horror movies and
stuff and it's like he uses the bass and
the music to like increase your heart
rate so there's a point where I try to
take a deep breath and I was like oh
crap like I can't breathe right I turned
to my friend I was like hey can you
breathe and he's like no why and I told
him about it and he was just like dude
that's so scary because it increases
like your anxiety heart rate blood
pressure and I was like oh I was like
freaking out a little bit I was like oh
this is crazy you know but just to be
clear you weren't in the crowd you were
just you you weren't so you weren't
being smashed by people that's why you
couldn't breathe
uh no that wasn't it even though we were
in the crowd
with the VIP section
before he came out no one was like
getting squished we were all pretty fast
probably because you were yeah you were
probably in the VIP section it was less
crowded there eh
when Travis came out everyone rushed the
VIP entrance for our area so it then
became squished
and but you said when you so when you
were leaving you saw some signs of stuff
that had gone wrong there
so my stepbrother his friend
uh she passed out during the performance
and she said that when she woke up she
was in the VIP area like the lounge and
she said that when she woke up that
that's where they were taking the the
dead bodies and other pastel people so
when we went to the area after the
concert we were in the same vicinity as
the dead bodies and we didn't even know
it that's how crazy it was and when we
were leaving the arena after the show
this was like about midnight for us
there was a a flipped car
like on the side of the road we think it
was an accident we don't think it was
like people going crazy and flipping
cars we think it was like an accident
that happened
you said you saw people crying but you
had no idea what happened
uh yeah there was girls uh around us
that were crying that were wanting to
leave when his show was performing so we
were like screaming at people like let
them through they want to go to the back
and they were pretty complicit they like
they go out really quick and we just
felt so bad because those we were
talking to them before and they've never
experienced a concert like this
all right Eileen well I'm glad that uh
you know you didn't have to experience
anything like Marco did but uh hey
um
thanks for calling and sharing your
story
yeah thank you so much
um
and then next up we have Cody who says
his girl went out with him and wanted so
wanted them to together drink his come
I'm just kidding I'm not that is a call
lined up but I'm not going to take it
girl he went out with wanted both of
them to drink his [ __ ] uh what
different uh different topics different
segments yeah yeah interesting
let's go right into that yeah no no
sideway at all
right
well oh boy
not a nightmare
it's so [ __ ] up
well you know we're going to end on a
good note
because we've compiled
it's related
but it's happy we've compiled examples
of other artists stopping their shows to
help the crowd
and it just is feel good I'll tell you
because you know you see these guys
being good guys and doing the right
thing and you would expect that most
artists know [ __ ] do this you know
um
but here
this is a
head on the [ __ ] Avenge Sevenfold is do
you they're like a mainstream metal band
[Music]
you guys all right we got a lot of time
out so hey someone's really hurting
there someone's very hurting there
[Applause]
yeah yeah they're knocked out cold you
gotta you gotta get them out
hey don't touch their neck let them let
some professional do it
Zach you're the Rock and roller isn't
this more rock and roll to actually like
stop and tell people to like that's like
isn't that the time old uh adage
especially even a grunge with moss
fishing it's like go crazy but you know
you got to take care of the people yeah
yeah I mean that's
somebody falls down you pick them up
like that's it's yeah it's supposed to
be fun you're not there to [ __ ] die
you're there yeah they're listening to
[ __ ] music and have a good time
you're not supposed to worry about
literally dying yeah it's it's just I I
just can't understand it what
I don't know it's [ __ ] well take solace
in knowing that here's post Malone he
had a great one
very proud of postie here for this one
yeah we're gonna say uh we don't want to
get claimed we've played like a billion
songs here so
throwing up to the YouTube Gods on this
one someone needs help down there
[Applause]
I mean this is the Governor's Ball huge
event and he saw it
look how people aren't being crushed to
death in the audience too right
it's packed
but not crushed to death back
[Applause]
is everybody all right
that that's that's cool
that's way cooler yeah
way cooler than letting people die and
telling people to jump off a [ __ ]
balcony
I love you
I thought I saw a different one actually
even close I think there might even be
another one
here's Dave Grohl of Foo Fighters and
Nirvana
um stopping a fight this was pretty cool
tricky with the music hey gotta be on
the trigger yeah
but the good news is they always stop
the music when yeah
when something happens
right there no no no no no no no you
don't [ __ ] fight at Marshall you
[ __ ] who's that who's that right
there let me see him who's fighting
right now who's fighting I'm
fine
look at me right here [ __ ]
accordion yeah
it's like one other junk man in the band
Travis Scott would be like kill him yeah
kill that man
get the [ __ ] out of my shell right now
get the [ __ ] out
get the [ __ ] out of my show
get the [ __ ] out of myself right now
you don't come to my show and fight you
come to my show and [ __ ] dance you
[ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here
I mean you think you'd have a vested
interest in having a safe environment
and get because like people are not
going to want to go to shows if they're
afraid of dying bro yep right I think
you have like a
a real vested interest in making sure
people are safe and having fun even
besides just being a good person you
know post has stopped the show multiple
times I'm seeing a bunch of different I
saw a really cool one of him that I
think was different than the one I just
watched if you can post more we can just
do a posty love
here's Kurt Cobain all the way back huh
Apparently one of the girls was being
inappropriately touched
waiting very uh Zach you got it yeah
right there yeah he just puts the dip
that's badass he just jumps into the
crowd and that's rock and roll yeah
that's rock and roll right there boy
no [ __ ] I mean rock and roll comes
from like the hippie movement ultimately
doesn't I mean it's peace and love
um they start laughing at him
look at him
[Applause]
the guy who was I guess inappropriately
touching the girl or something
um
here is oh you got the the other post
one
oh I saw the ASAP Rocky one that was
good yeah keep sending him guys because
I know there's a lot of really good ones
I think this is the one I saw no it's
not
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
left during his white trash
[Applause]
[Applause]
and she's short and she needs help you
see her and you see her there she is
right there
what the [ __ ] is he doing actually
caring about his audience don't you know
people are supposed to die of yourselves
yeah and let's not forget that you know
he says she's short she's you know she
can't I mean 14 year olds [ __ ] died
that's crazy
so it makes me think one of my uh
favorite bands of all time is band uh
fugazi were very famous for um stopping
shows when people are getting violent to
the extent that they actually would come
to shows with envelopes with cash in
them for the ticket amount
um ready to go and if somebody was like
starting fights or being violent or
something like that they would pull them
up on stage give them an envelope with a
refund and kick them out of the building
that's nice even they would give them a
refund
sweet way to kick someone out
here's ASAP Rocky you know watch out
[Music]
the bars pick those girls up bro take
the girls up take the [ __ ] girls up
what's wrong
[Applause]
get the [ __ ] up
rolling loud
[Music]
that's good
you know it was great that's how you
control a crowd
Irish singer Niall Horan
let's see I think that there's a good
chance that this show is going to get
canceled oh this is from one day ago by
the way security is my responsibility
okay there is a ton of room down the
back of this room
everyone
[Applause]
and we don't want anyone getting hurt or
squashed and this swaying is very
dangerous
and it's not going to work for the rest
of the night let's organize this before
we go any further okay that there's a
good chance that this is how about that
huh
foreign
I mean someone is well like toured and
played as Travis Scott totes you know
should know better
Slipknot bro you're talking about like
hardcore [ __ ]
uh death Rock
I don't know what do you call slip knot
maybe I'm not super Metal band yeah I
mean you think metal you're like you
know people are going crazy they're like
new metal no I mean for the most part
you know metal bands and punk bands
they're the ones that because the
culture is too mosh and you know have
really rambunctious shows or whatever
the the flip side of that is like I said
I mean the the
etiquette is that you're supposed to
look out for people because you don't
actually want people to get hurt you
want them to have fun so and sometimes
these bands are the best about these
kind of things and something on Slipknot
particularly they do something called
The Wall of Death where split the crowd
and you run into each other
however
they make sure that they keep it as safe
as possible
that does that actually sound like a bad
idea I have to say but okay here is uh
um
here's the lead singer from slit slip
knot
[Applause]
okay maybe you know cares about safety
like that
maybe Blessed to the Wall of Death stuff
not familiar with that though but if you
know
and friend of the show
um legendary mark rubier
always coming out always delivering
oh
yeah yo let's build this [ __ ] here we go
is
it
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] yes can we use that
[Applause]
what
what
what's going on
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's up
medic we need a medic we need a medic
over here oh [ __ ] we got it we got him
we there we go there we go there we go
what's going on
what's going on baby he's got what's
that oh he's having oh [ __ ] okay all
right well everyone stops stimulus for a
second okay we're just gonna stop that
stimulus there we go let's let them have
it out
you know what I'm going to be having a
seizure yeah it sounds like it yeah
there you go Mark rubier cares for him
Legend
there's a lot of these they're they're
oh sure we made a new video
a lot another friend of the show logic
hmm
let's see it very carefully very calmly
moves like this right now side to side
everybody that's in the middle move
thank you very much
please keep quiet
foreign
[Music]
Bobby
good guy and here's one thing I want to
say I can't tell you how many times this
[ __ ] happens at a concert right I want
you guys to make sure that you feel okay
and you're good is it another one but
let's do the same thing somebody pick
them up and everybody right here look at
me everybody look at me and I want you
to spread like this
[Music]
that's the thing though he even goes
like everybody be quiet you know you can
people listen you're like the only
person that can actually help that's the
thing up there right
yeah
any other any other ones you guys want
to watch before we move on to shoe nice
well there's also the satanic uh
oh here's a good one yeah we'll okay
here's a final one Adele Adele Adele
what was the chat right tell Adele
in love when the photo of her was the
threads uh shut up
oh go ahead
please
she's crazy
they go hard I heard their box pits are
the most vicious
[Applause]
yeah so you know this stuff happens all
the time at shows and it really is their
responsibility to keep people safe
[Music]
um
let's see I know this isn't but this is
the best one you've seen which one is
this cam
oh Lincoln Park yes this is a great one
Lincoln Park
[Music]
yo
we got a little problem up here pick
them up right everybody up
sorry you guys
we gotta look out for safety first for
real nobody gets hurt that's number one
hey yo don't play this [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] again if you guys get up if you
guys are all right okay watch yourselves
hey yo man we know we've been stressing
all night
about being cool
and this is the reason why
[Applause]
let's go over it one more time when
someone Falls what do you do
when someone Falls what do you do
that's right people
now that's a cool [ __ ]
whatever happened to that now it's like
jump off the balcony [ __ ] are you gonna
do it or not I mean it still is yeah I
know I'm just an outlier but like what
the [ __ ] you shouldn't even be able to
do that she'd be like nah I'm not
booking you if you're telling people to
jump off a [ __ ] balcony you're not
doing shows
period
that's a full sun moment
yeah I'm surprised he can still get
insured after uh
everything all those previous incidents
we went over but I guess when sued
arrested
when you're one of the biggest artists
in the world you can get away with it up
until something like this happens
how's that chair by the way are you
comfortable I see yourself more used to
it yeah yeah you can't see Dan but he's
sitting like cross-legged crisscross
applesauce baby cry crisscross
applesauce
and we we figured that out I was uh
inappropriately calling it Indian style
which is what I don't know so we're
killing that crisscross applesauce
hold on
a little bit
oh time to ascend
can we get it do we need you know what
we need it a guy who's a long shot
damn so that we can really tell when
you're moving
you know because the the close-up face
shot doesn't really do the chair
adjusted it's kind of true you can't I
do like that it looks like I'm in the
cockpit of a of a Mecca or a Mech that
is good but we need a long shot to
complement it it looks more like that
too when I turn on the overheads like
that it's got a very um
a Pacific Rim Vibe well here we're
setting up a little side cam there maybe
we can get a shot how's that coming
[Music]
yeah just don't show my screens
got the hentai open he always has hentai
open over there I've got the call-in
studio and it's got some barriers and
stuff yeah now that's a shot
now that's a shot baby
I love it the [ __ ] bar poorly place
it's all good
right exactly
awesome there we go
yeah so now people of course have all
the conspiracy fuel they need to
conclude that this was a Satanic ritual
by Travis Scott of course people always
take things too far
let's see here
this can't be serious the batboy [ __ ]
pay attention see you on the other side
meaning after death
not a coincidence that eight people died
the circle around though in AstroWorld
represents being hypnotized
[Music]
they have I think different voices okay
two
it was a conspiracy to kill eight people
they were summoning the Demons of Hell
to end Humanity
the other annoying one that you hate Dan
wouldn't work as well with this
the woman that girl who talks like this
AstroWorld conspiracy world was a
demonic ritual
eight people yeah favorite crazy
Christian video
yeah uh this one
there's some with a lot of views that
one doesn't it's pretty underground this
one has 20 000 likes so this is pretty
mainstream Trevor's got astroworld's
Festival Satanic ritual question mark
was Travis Scott's astral World Festival
a Satanic ritual let's talk about it in
Houston Texas clearly yes Travis Scott
had a concert leaving eight people dead
and many injured the dead ranging from
ages 14 to 27 and the injured being as
young as 10 years old I personally
believe that there's much more than the
media is telling us okay this incident
is much deeper than what most people
think this is the flyer of the festival
with the All-Seeing Eye Inside hand this
symbol represents hypnotizing people and
taking control of them the side of the
fire literally says see you on the other
side look at the shirt Travis Scott was
wearing it shows blue people walking
through a portal and turning into red
people Travis Scott also dropped a song
called Escape Plan the day before the
concert dude it's a bad boy meme look at
some of the lyrics and people dying for
the chain around my neck That's Life
Alert he's saying Life Alert he made a
Life Alert reference for old people that
have like a necklace that they hit he's
falling and he can't get up yo this is a
Life Alert reference that's hard people
dying for the chain around my neck
That's Life Alert he's saying that
people are always literally wrote Life
lyrics his wealth for his success and
it's time people wake up and see this
for what it really is this Festival was
a Satanic ritual I just dropped an
in-depth YouTube video explaining what
really happened
man we have the uh satanologist here
demonologist uh who's figured out no no
need for an investigation guys the 80s
are back baby
call off the satanic panic
call off the investigation
this dude on Tick Tock figured it out
this one has 2.3 million likes this is a
big one my heart and prayer go out to
all those who oh wait this is a demonic
one so they were saying uh because this
is how we started off the concert with
this Phoenix like this bird and it's
supposed to symbolize
cleansing and death I know what a
phoenix is it's not demonic it's rebirth
they think it's jesus-esque
right man Phoenix yeah is associated
with resurrection and Reaper
that's a stretch guys
okay whatever
um
here is actually we have a a photo of
the entrance of Travis Scott it was a
gateway to Hell actually although it
does look like the entrance what is this
you sent me Kim
oh for real okay so Metropolis is a
gateway to Hell
yeah the one above where it's side by
side with the Bosch painting is pretty
epic by the way the dude whose
girlfriend wants him to drink his own
[ __ ] is still on the hold
should we pop in I don't know let's see
what he thinks about AstroWorld yeah I'm
wondering if he's uh
yeah maybe we'll let's let's talk to him
do not come all right let's talk to Cody
all right but about AstroWorld yeah Cody
uh thanks for staying on the line
you with me Cody yes yeah no problem
yeah so one here yeah I can hear you so
what did you think about AstroWorld what
do you think about that old thing
I think that was pretty crazy yeah
definitely and uh
I I I enjoyed being a a passing Segway
earlier that was very nice for me okay
great just to hear my name said was an
honor all right well thanks for calling
appreciate you take care okay buddy
[Laughter]
appreciate it Cody I didn't want to hear
that stuff
I just wanted to say hi
since he was waiting on hold for so long
damn your ex's ass we've had enough uh
gross calls for forever
well how long we've been going I think
we did a full show here eh oh yeah we
were at three hours oh [ __ ] so we keep
we got channel five and we've got
unusual okay we'll do it next time
Friday maybe or whatever next week
well thanks for
um watching everybody
any comments and you guys want to
any super chats or something or stuff
you want to read off before I sign up I
had quite a few uh new members from
accounts like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] piss and oh
shoot we still at it how many is he out
love love what's the final count is it
99 no we need one more one more let's
round it out
five hundred dollars
unfucking real
[Applause]
unreal
okay
I'm just blowing oh sh I'm blown away I
I'm just
it has to be shoe nobody's spending 500
to promote his channel
no I don't believe it I don't think it's
him who would do that love yeah I don't
know I don't know you need to have a
motive why how is this trolling they're
promoting I'll drop a conspiracy go
ahead it's uh Liam okay let's say
there's another YouTuber out there who
doesn't like you wants to troll you
while you're live maybe because usually
clown on him during these lives and he
doesn't want to get in trouble with
YouTube so he's like who can I blame it
on then he takes Chewie shoe he's the
scapegoat
if someone does want to troll you who
troll who control you oh they're
trolling me now okay I mean it's not a
very good troll to just Spam stuff in
the chat it's like who cares he's giving
us money
has a mindset of a child okay 20 year
old stuff like that okay so they want to
troll me yeah okay go ahead they're
troll in your chat yeah but they don't
want to get in trouble with YouTube so
they can't do it themselves
so they do a little slide but why would
they say follow shoe on Cameo and
subject and you don't think it's someone
else why wouldn't they just do like
anti-semitic and horrible [ __ ] that
would like be more offensive because
then they don't have a person to blame
but they did they haven't they haven't
really trolled me have they
well they think they are because they're
murdered it would bother them so they
think do you have someone in mind that
you're theorizing about I don't know
maybe someone with a beard you think Kim
star just spent 500 in his whole day
maybe I mean you were well you're
allowed to have an opinion you're not
saying it was him it's not slander it's
not defamation
I want to put it past them everyone
wants me to watch channel five
all right I'll watch Channel Five Guys
just mind you when I had 150 followers
he would make fun of my wife block me
and then unblock me and this is before I
worked for you I was a nobody so I could
definitely see him put a little bit more
effort yeah I'm getting on this A B
train I think we need to start believing
him a little bit that's true yeah I have
a good point I'm getting on this this
well AB is always like he's like right
about these things but like in kind of a
sideways indirect way
how was she sideways right about it I
accept that well because the Liam thing
it was like oh it was oh the fact that
he didn't want you to get a copyright
claim means that he's looking for a job
or whatever which like
didn't I mean anybody could just have
I'm gonna kill them or whatever but then
he ended up being ripe yeah
wait what the [ __ ] what is this like I
don't think that on its own was actually
very strong actually I do think it was
an interesting observation right looking
back right exactly so this one's a
stretch for me it's just it doesn't make
sense to he's he's paying me and
promoting shoe how is that a troll right
because he gets to troll you and not
take me to the blame how is it a troll
but it's not a trolls
they what did he say he made fun of ela
yeah but Shu does that he said he was a
horse that's something I mean I'm not
saying it's it could be shoe definitely
could be his Joker that's something she
would say I'm just saying it's not 100
shoe
well she was in his car in those videos
on his phone there's no way you can do
that on a phone well she doesn't know I
think she must be paying someone because
he's not right he obviously doesn't it's
Ryan Kavanaugh so but I also think she
was living in his car possibly yeah do
you like the theory that it's a Ryan
Kavanaugh
oh he's got the money he's got the means
he's got the motivation he already has
the botnet
he has the bot he has access to them
yeah
totally let's see
that's the theory by the way this is not
an accident I think that that is somehow
trolling you um this is yeah he is
Boomer enough yeah
again not an accusation thank you thank
you peace and love just an opinion a
theory we're speculating here I would
call that a frog and I'm just gonna
throw this out Keem starts retiring
maybe he wants a job oh you think he's
trying to get on the show
you can't beat him join him you know
I like that there I'm team maybe on this
one keemstar if you want a job email me
we can talk
you could be our [ __ ] uh Aaron boy
you can clean the toilets
and get us coffee in the morning I'll
pay you like uh what's minimum wage in
L.A 12 an hour
yeah I'll pay you 15 buddy
and we have health benefits and [ __ ]
401K you know what I'm saying
I mean cleaning my toilets would be an
honor for keemstar I mean we clogged the
toys a lot we could use help with that
so yeah it might be the man for your job
honored yeah keemstar can finally stiff
my [ __ ] something he's been wanting to
do for a while I'm sure
it's really what but besides YouTube
really what else is he qualified to do
other than clean toilets well he if he's
out here you know he can do those uh
Park boxing events he's always wanted to
do bum fights you can bring back bum
fights sure man whatever he wants
kavas do see people are saying
I like that
all right people want me to watch
channel five and I'll commit to doing it
under one condition only
we gotta order food first
okay what you want
oh my God yeah I forgot yeah this is 50
minutes long you guys it's gonna take me
so long to watch all right I'm gonna do
it I committed I'm gonna do it
what do you want for food what do y'all
want what do you want what though uh
what do I want
you know what guys if we're gonna do
this I gotta take like a short break I
gotta go pee
I'll be back in like five minutes how's
that sound
because otherwise I'm just gonna end
this so give me a little just give me a
little break
do you guys want to suggest food is that
suggesting Pizza I just want to shout
out someone in the chat named flips who
said killer clean star which killer
client star clean star because you can
clean the toilets oh Killer Queen Stars
I thought that was a reference to my
last name killer Klein star also works
Olivia you want to come sit with us now
that you're done
you so Pizza I mean okay I mean wow wow
I'm open though you guys don't have to
what are you guys you guys got no
opinions that was the chat was spamming
Pizza
so I was just throwing it out there
seeing tacos Pizza
chicken fingers I don't know where
chicken fingers came from but yeah it
also works what do uh Ian you have a Sam
you guys usually have good ideas what do
you want
uh
veggie burger
good option
did you grow kind of gross smell lately
what did you guess
I'm just gonna say veggie grow oh you
guys don't okay so if you guys don't
want veggie grill let's do it you don't
want veggie girl I don't want veggie
grill
Follow the Leader much huh
my vote is no Chinese my vote's no on
Veggie Grill just I can't do Chinese
that one place we get is just it's so
oppressive to me
all the dishes are so gnarly I took a
bite of like every single piece of
orange chicken and there was like a
tendon each oh no I couldn't no no no no
we can't do that
that's a big ask
you gotta look past the chunks of bone
the last thing that Sam you got this for
me it was like spare ribs those are
gnarly I almost shipped the [ __ ]
tooth I'm like
well you can't eat them you gotta take
the bones out yeah he really hated that
dish I've had that dish sack it was not
it was difficult it was horrible it was
difficult
like the flavors were good but it's a
tiny little bone like this big yeah it's
more bone than me so and it's very fatty
too yeah I don't want to have to go to
the [ __ ] dentist
right
[ __ ] Pizza calzones for life wait are
you interested are you in favor of pizza
or camera are you calzone boy well he
said [ __ ] Pizza though oh he wants a
cousin yeah he wants a freaking calzone
the window is open for me right now well
aren't you supposed to go crazy then not
I'm trying to eat healthy still when the
wind when the window is open my friends
we feast
yeah I remember you did that for a while
yeah that was one of my things
the suggestions are not being very
helpful I'm reading the chat I love
pizza and I love people
right Papa John says Pizza asada fries
um
did someone say FICA
calzones you guys want calzones
let's just get fit okay so that is not
healthy guys I'm going to McDonald's
later
yeah do you support someone like Ty
Travis Scott
depends on the place I like Thai though
that's true we'll have Ty
oh my God you guys this is intense I
need I need ideas it's tough someone's
got to make a decision here
[Music]
is so crazy like who that's so specific
we've never had calzone is there a
calzone place I don't think there's like
a calzone Place probably Pizza anywhere
that has pizza would have cows Pizza
well not necessarily I don't know I've
personally I've I've been eating a few
calzones lately and I feel like it's
just like a shitty version of pizza
you've been eating calzones come here
and could debate okay
debate me prove me wrong change my mind
killer cam
go ahead debate me on calzones calzone
is a double decker of a pizza it's way
better it's not a double decker though
it's like they fold it up and usually
they don't eat they don't even put sauce
in it that's the best part that's the
worst part I hate sauce and pizza at
least but so we're different sauce
okay then then I'm open for anything I
don't want to dictate the calzone oh you
were talking shame him big game a second
ago no this is interesting because yeah
you're I guess you're the target
audience for the calzone
so that's just that okay thank you yep
thank you thank you Cam calzone
well we got Friday was good
moving on Friday I don't want to see the
play I don't remember the place but it
was good
oh it was uh Cafe place
what are we in for oh mine was boring
someone got me a salad oh yeah I know
mine was dank
okay here's the thing Ian you decide
whatever you say we order go there we go
uh well I brought some lunch so you're
not even gonna eat it dude he he brought
salmon today yeah salmon Sam was heating
it up and I'm like I think something
died in here or something it was pretty
stinky I want one but it was it was
awesome I've heard of offices Banning uh
fish from the office I think we need to
put the kibosh on it man
wait how do we feel about Indian food
are we out on how's that
too much I enjoy that pretty it's pretty
uh
don't you got salmon
what I'm saying Ian has salmon so Ramen
no no no no no no no
Five Guys
let me look through my previous office
is this what you guys wanted is this
what you wanted when you said to watch
channel five
look what you've done King Kong ain't
got [ __ ] on me
um people want to pull let's let the
people decide actually
yeah let's put it to a pool
okay ready then just put every place
I'll tell you the options what one
Mexican we eat
Mexican two burger burger three Indian
four Thai
five calzone
oh YouTube only lets you have four
options okay so let's let's remove time
Indian let's be real here what time I I
was gonna vote for Ty
it's like my favorite food so maybe we
should just get Thai well okay so yeah
let's just get Thai food no no we're
doing the poll we're going too far
go ahead so we've got so read the
options to me Mexican burger Thai how
about calzone and calzone yeah that's
okay what about smelly work fish
uh Sweden yeah do we have another Canada
for you Ian oh we do we actually do have
a backup we have another candidate well
why didn't you say it so earlier
could save us a lot of time how do you
pronounce it strowman
I'm watching seriously all right so
people a lot of people are passionate
about Mexican interestingly
which we didn't even uh mention
why didn't we include Sharkies as an
option if we did okay guys can you vote
Mexican I want Mexican
you know when I almost said
you said set up the poll and then
immediately the first option you threw
out was Mexican it's obvious that that's
what's in your heart no
it's like that old trick that when you
when you flip a coin and they say like
right as you flip it uh you'll you'll
know what you truly want because you'll
know where you want that coin to land
well the people have voted for Tai
thanks to Dan Dan you totally now you
[ __ ] up that whole bunch I wanted
Mexican bro just get Mexican then why
are we still talking about
I say we all get tied and get Dan
Mexican
let's just order Mexican food
all right thank you Paul thank you
Mexican because that's what he wanted to
decided not to listen
I mean I I definitely rather Mexican
than Thai that's from Mexican sounds
fantastic okay great I'm gonna go pee
I'll be back in five minutes you want to
play the cool
um
um
you guys want to carry on without me or
should we go to a break
let's go to a quick break
roll the cool music playlist
okay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
death death
death
s
[Music]
what was that death to all about death
deaths
what was that what was that what was
that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
amen
[Music]
ities
[Music]
and like yesterday in the office I was
like man I'm so pissed at you but I
don't want to tell you why it's because
I was about to ship my pants
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and although you just threw a stop for
him
I'm so over this car I'm getting it back
to you
[Music]
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
foreign
this is donut taste
[Applause]
what up pimps
[Music]
another unoriginal production
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see Max until I die big nation my heck
in life
hilarious YouTube acting like they
scared of us restricted mode ain't fair
to us so the elocliners take care of us
just for fun
all right we had a few food Mutiny
during our short break yep we're getting
sandwiches now just as an update
all right but let's get straight to here
a little bonus content for our uh fupa
Troopers everybody's been great here
today uh supportive gang we love you so
we are sticking around
for the bonus end of this
so Channel 5 Utah rap Festival
here we go
without further ado
I made it to the front baby made it to
the front
let's go suicide suicide boys baby dude
he's so red
we're off to a great start
my goodness
[Music]
come on dude how this seems like the
worst environment for that
yeah that's a bad Vibe right there dude
someone get this man some water he's
like red
he needs some milk
milk you think
I was quoting the sound bite I need some
milk semen is another type of milk
this is actually a really interesting
thing I
is there people in Utah Salt Lake City
who hate the Mormons is there like a
whole cultural Warfare going on because
you know
the Mormon headquarters is in Salt Lake
City the the vast majority of people
that live there are Mormon
so it's kind of interesting is the story
of the Utah Pioneers who were they what
did they believe
what does it mean to be a v-line thug a
villain Thug is the one that's you know
you're hardcore bro a real life
[ __ ] Thug bro that real thug
life bro that v-line Thug Life v-line
Thug Life bro does anyone know what VLAN
is is that just like an area
it's like a brand
a brand
it's like hard to explain I don't vlone
is a brand these [ __ ] are thugs
because they wear a brand that's not
very thuggish
that's what they're screaming about
there you go you guys think Teddy fresh
is expensive a 300 hoodie with a print
on the front
Jesus
I hate to say it bro but wearing a brand
is kind of the opposite of being a thug
shout out to my favorite brand
[Laughter]
or Counter Culture
I don't think buying a 300 hoodie makes
you a thug my dude
it's the most peel on Thug thing you've
ever done man I stole a pocket knife the
other day okay dude first of all so
funny and by the way this guy looks like
Macaulay Culkin
do we know it's not him
why not to be a long talk bro I'll be
if you had to kill one person who would
it be probably Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton bro all that [ __ ] fake email
[ __ ] about them talking about pizza but
really they're talking about molesting
children in a whole [ __ ] time of
child trafficking bro yeah this guy
missed the memo the guy who's still
upset about pizza again
he drank the pizza pizza gate Kool-Aid
and he still hasn't recovered
apparently some acid in that Kool-Aid as
well
double view on plug it in
Eminem's probably like delete me from
this conversation
murder gang [ __ ] what's on your mind
right now
you look goofy as hell what does that
mean big in a good way like I guess
depends on how you you know how would
you describe yourself
that question threw me off where are you
guys from Seattle
vibing out talking to people saying
what's up so y'all just came here to do
this we had a hectic few weeks on the
road and after covering a few different
events we decided to come to a music
festival to see what's going on dude are
you a cop
what Heroes I feel like if you're
generally asking someone like why they
don't like cops you kind of [ __ ] with
cops that's the vibe you're getting I'm
just playing I [ __ ] with Seattle for
real who's your favorite white rapper of
all time by the way this guy who's like
I guess cool Thug Life whatever such a
fashion just such a fashion slave I mean
it's just not Thug
why they don't like cops
his cousin that like
his mom smoked or something when he was
pregnant that's the vibe you're getting
what I'm just playing I [ __ ] with
Seattle for real who's your favorite
look at this outfit Gucci hat babe
shorts like such a fashion slave good
intentions t-shirt and then just 50
shoes that's not thuggy bro
you're a fashion slave you're you're
part of the corporate system dude shout
out Zan I [ __ ] with little Zanny cool
also like bro you just lost everything
when you shouted out little Dan
who's your favorite who's the best
rapper that lives Lil xan easily
Dan beat me to the trigger
yeah he [ __ ] beat me to the trigger
with it [ __ ]
what's your name Andrew
oh wait someone's FaceTiming let's see
who it is
so good did they pulled that clip
damn your homie didn't answer bro I'm on
camera
it's like uh his best friend his
roommate you don't know him runs all
this [ __ ] you know what I'm saying if
you can ask Lil xan's roommate to tell
Lil xan ask Lil xan's ask closance
manager to ask clothes and if he [ __ ]
with Andrew Callahan and Channel 5 News
Channel 5 news breaking news breaking
news
[Music]
we're here in Salt Lake City at The Hive
Music Festival got Wildfire smoke in the
air we got Delta in the building the
baby's not performing Zero fatalities by
the way at this Festival just to put in
context there
that I'm aware of and also the breaking
news the suicide boys are not performing
anger continuing to grow tonight as the
hive Festival dresses on in the bad air
after Spencer just mentioned it and
after Headliners canceled rapper the
baby will not take the stage tonight it
comes after he made homophobic comments
a week ago fellas if you ain't sucking
[ __ ] dick in the parking lot put
yourself on that was a great one
so wait did he not show up because he
because they canceled his [ __ ] because
of what he said or is it because of the
wildfire
oh they dropped him huh
interesting Grammy nominated rapper then
suggested people with HIV die within two
to three weeks you didn't show up today
with HIV AIDS essential transmitted
disease did it make you die two three
weeks
it just it cracks me up like I'm just
thinking back on the what he said
you know it's like where did you read
that my fact
just so openly homophobic it's just
laughable
yeah but we just got our 100th soon I
spam
[Applause]
and he still hasn't emailed us even
after you've named your email right Dan
um well after I said that I got like 500
emails so I might be buried somewhere in
there but we had already moved on to the
um
so I'll keep it coming guys that's a
hundred come on don't stop now you only
have 100 alts shoe nice come on that's
weak [ __ ]
100 a hundred alts that's rookie numbers
bro
like love how many alts do you have
a couple thousand yeah exactly rookie
numbers come on now
baby I'm Still rocking with the baby
everybody makes mistakes sometimes he
said he's sorry follow me on Instagram
can we put the baby and Trump in the
Coliseum together let's let him fight to
the death we can toss Epstein in there
with him as well
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so our uh that's a wrap for I guess
all these people are like rappers
because everyone's promoting their
SoundCloud and Instagram and [ __ ]
love that for them
God I'm a rapper too you guys should
follow my SoundCloud
it's called Lowell Klein which means a
little low whoa whoa all right
little Lil Baby
music Timo B on the beat coming with the
heat position I know I'm [ __ ] got me
on a trip
that me and my homie took the time to
[ __ ] actually do it and grow them
this long you feel like people hate on
it I don't know why people hate so hard
appropriation or some [ __ ] like that
what's your goal for the night for the
night
what'd you say if Zillow was standing
right here you know this guy Zilla I've
never heard of him but the people in the
audience love him you got Intel on that
Ian I'm not familiar with him no really
hmm I'm out of touch
Ian's officially out of touch he knew
everybody up until this moment
oh [ __ ] babies that's really funny
yo pull up that photo of the Matrix
twins you guys remember from Matrix two
the twins that like could go through
walls yeah so
they're the beta version of The Matrix
twins
so true
it's kind of funny they have dreads in
this I don't know why it's just beta the
beta version
so true
bro I give him a piece of my hair bro
I'm gonna try to figure it out for you
[Music]
by the way how many fatalities were at
this Festival
I actually checked once you said that
and I don't see a report yeah no
fatalities so interesting how that
happens
I guess we probably shouldn't play the
music so let's fast forward give it to
you he actually seems like a cool dude
he's the biggest fan he wants to cut his
largest dread off and uh and give it to
you
that sounds [ __ ] nasty but
I'll let him do it okay should we do it
right now yeah let's do it [ __ ] it
dude the fact Andrew's got real clock
now he can set this [ __ ] up this is why
I'm here right now I love Zilla and
that's my [ __ ] what's going through your
mind right now this is some legendary
[ __ ] that he's able to set this up
that's clout that you can't buy from the
mainstream media real [ __ ] z-line Thug
[ __ ] v-line Thug [ __ ]
you're backstage you're about to meet
your idol and give him one of your
dreadlocks it's just unreal I feel like
this is just fake it's real it's real
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] way
oh [ __ ] way man
what's up dude
is it worth it I think so is it not
that's up to you man
[ __ ] I can't get it man you think but
what do you guys think about where he's
cutting it like it could be
I think it should be lower down because
you're just gonna have a little quarter
dread
I'm sorry just
look at his face he's not wanting that
dread [ __ ] man it's not coming out
there it goes
oh he's got a little alfalfa I don't
know looks like a little Harry Potter
wand hmm
I'll say a little churro but yeah it
does kind of look more like a wand
what to do with this it actually smells
pretty good it literally smells like
shampoo
you can do a Freestyle right now no no I
can't do a freestyle ten dollars in your
cash app right now cash app the best way
to pay people to Freestyle the best way
to get paid for freestyling cash app
cash app cash app [ __ ] greatest
integration too by the way yep fantastic
[ __ ] my mind is racing right now you're
freestyle
back row seats
helpful a skeet you well we had a caller
who was who was oh got him back on the
line yeah get back the the Skeets
about this Channel 5 video [ __ ] feet
stand by a big tree put dildos into the
which came from Italy
I can't think of anything
like blades cutting up the [ __ ]
instrumental every day and I do my
[ __ ] thing you have any tattoos nah
I'm only 17. that don't matter I'm gonna
get a [ __ ] time I'm broke I spent all my
money on this place
it wasn't worth it it wasn't worth it
what do you mean he just gave you his
dread this seems like it was pretty
worth it for him he didn't even get to
see his favorite artists
the baby
should grab on my dick like a handle
little [ __ ] I have on Jesus sandals
[Music]
Eeny Meeny I'ma roll up a blunt take a
smoke we could dance on a pole on the
floor Drop It Low running back we could
bow she wanna ride the bro she wanna
ride the bro she wanna ride the boat
what does that mean I think she wants to
have sex with my friends which friend
was that in reference to in reference to
Alex here
she wants to have sex with me do you
know your SPM uh Haley what's my SPM
Strokes per minute at maximum velocity
seven wouldn't it be like a pump or
thrust per minute like a stroke per
minute seems like a solo activity right
[Music]
so a Thrust no not thrust wait it's a
pump a pump no no wait [ __ ] now I'm
confused let me go back uh Haley what's
my SPM oh stroke no stroke wouldn't
wouldn't well yeah you still refer to it
as a stroke I've heard a stroke yeah
yeah yeah a stroke is like a self
something you do to yourself no I agree
they say like front stroke backstroke
they're using hip-hop all the time oh
for real they're referred to like
swimming in a girl or butterfly stroke
but she said seven something's quite low
that's not a lot that's quite slow well
let's do let's see seven would be like
once every nine seconds approximately so
you're correct yeah that's pretty slow
I'm running I'm sitting about two or
three so
per minute at maximum velocity seven
okay
you guys [ __ ] with zans yeah yeah what's
your favorite kind of Zen fatties The
Fat Boys the blue ones I was at a music
festival and I did like nine different
drugs and then I sipped some like cold
water extract lean I was like yeah so
um
did he just put his cash up
like what was that look at this hell
yeah what's your favorite kind of Zan
fatties The Fat Boys the blue ones I was
at a music festival and I did like nine
different drugs and I yeah isn't this a
cash Shopper job this musician his name
is Bibi no money that's his name oh okay
how did you know him Ian my brother
likes him a lot are these guys pretty
famous
I think they're they're you know
semi-popular Sam likes the guy next to
him it's a young gravy weirdly I
actually knew about that guy too
these people are out I usually and I'm
usually Boomer as [ __ ] when did I'm
maybe I'm a boomer but like when did
these names get so [ __ ] wild BB no
money young gravy I mean what's the
other guy's name low foreskin
I think little foreskin was donating in
the chat earlier spamming right that's
true a little dreidel I should be septic
it was septic foreskin my rap name
should be a little Klein foreskin which
is a little little foreskin
these guys are kind of like comedic as
well okay okay that's that's Olivia you
want to come sit with us yeah just audio
I just uh
playing the live stream for some reason
my bad
sip some like cold water extract lean I
was like lying on a carpet
I had no idea what's going on but that's
a flex we were gonna make a softcore
porn and I asked my parents I sat there
now I was like look I have a really good
music music video idea I need to make
the software point out and my mom was
like I have friends
my mom was super down for me she was
like yeah do a software porn it's all
good and then
his mom wasn't with it I have actually
not I swear to God I have I haven't
flaccid
I love my trip down is
have you nodded have any of you guys
nutted flaccid I don't I can't say that
I have done that
I guess that's why it's a remarkable
story to share yeah I think it's I'm I'm
looking up what that even means you know
what that means
you're Googling it well I suppose yeah
describe what you're seeing there when
you look up the top search says six
amazing penis facts from the New York
Post oh read those I want to hear what
six amazing Phoenix facts turn away
Olivia send me that I want that New York
Post article I want to read those
I suppose it could happen during a wet
dream
I think your torque during the white
yeah exactly yeah
never had one I don't know if the uh
it's just safe to click I mean it works
nice uh I love yo this is me when I'm
trying
I can't see it where is it
tiny wiener gang
all right number one let's see
um let's all the bolded ones it's a
semen displacement advice while you
probably think of your dong as a device
designed to inject semen
humans just another type of milk
it's also engineered to remove the semen
of competitors
you know The Ridge at the base of your
penis head
the raised part just north of your shaft
well you're thrusting in and out of your
partner the ridge takes away the semen
of any foes who may have slid in before
you
I mean how much sex is going on where
it's still fresh in there the fourth one
acknowledges you can ejaculate while
limp
[Music]
that is an amazing penis fact oh wow
it can survive decapitation
um
tennis sodomy
fantasy to me
is a procedure that involves removing
part or all of the penis
it can be necessary if you have penis
cancer
but like the Headless Horseman your
dipstick doesn't die if you cut off its
head
you can still urinate have sex and
ejaculate how that's good
finds a study from Brazil um
don't knock Brazilian researchers like
that
just saying we need peer review on that
it can predict how you're uh that is an
amazing penis fact thank you
it can predict how your brain works men
with whose philosophy penises hang to
the left
that's the majority of us
may have left brain dominant
suggests research okay there you go
so if your penis hangs to the left
you're more left brain than it bangs to
the right
you might be more a right brand
no because because left brain controls
the right side right that's interesting
the left brand
um so if your dick dangles to the left
that could explain why you're graded
algebra
yeah that is one amazing penis fact
one of six and now here here's where we
would come to the relevant uh
information
it can ejaculate while limp
while boners and ejaculation are usually
a package deal
you don't have to be hard to expel semen
shows a study
from California's Oakland Medical Center
I'm glad we had a whole study for that
one
I guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it no I'm taking this very
seriously Carlos I assure you
what are we gonna do without men
their penises hang to the left
toxic masculinity dropping off the tips
we have penises we have men whose penis
is hang to the left we have men whose
penis is hang to the right they're doing
impossible things they're they're
ejaculating while they're flaccid
what would we do without impossible
things with men men
Olivia you could never ejaculate while
flaccid what would we do without men
it's impossible
we're doing impossible things where
would we be
[Music]
according and we've confirmed it can
eject semen up to eight feet
I guess in my Heyday Maybe
oh that's that's hard to believe eight
feet I mean that's some distance
a little sharpshooter huh
according to a study well hold on this
is a this is a study conducted by the
University of Indiana where they lined
up dudes oh it's us
what do they play Limp Biscuit or some
[ __ ] yeah why the [ __ ] are they
researching this all right everybody
line up
on your mark get set go
then they got people out there like you
know when people do Javelin they've got
people with flags out there right
[ __ ] the uh the landing position and
they say unfortunately there's not much
new data backing this up
but there was a recent study from
Cornell
which found force with which you
ejaculate corresponds directly with how
satisfied you feel
with your orgasm
fascinating finally guys
just to round it off a study from France
looked at the shape of your salon during
sex
when you and your partner in the
missionary position your penis
uh Smiles I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
it forms a smile I mean what are you
talking about
the New York Post isn't this a news well
isn't this a news publication what the
[ __ ] is this
it's a dog [ __ ] anybody make those the
New York Post is sort of like a tabloid
surprising I mean it is news technically
but
it's not the uh the highest brow uh have
you have you ever accidentally hit
yourself in the face back in the day
with the
ejaculate yeah come on
um talking about the face like chess
sure chest come on stop
obviously
I'm answering your question the answer
is no who's who's hit themselves in the
face almost I dodged it like Neo I'll be
honest I'll be honest I once hit myself
in the eye on accident
and it was [ __ ] horrible my eye was
so irritated and [ __ ] up all day it
was all red and I was on a family
vacation with my family and they were
like what's wrong with your eyes oh no
yeah try explaining that one to your
parents
you were just pirate nobody just me huh
all right [ __ ] it I'll fess up to it
what are you just doing this to back up
Ethan no no no I was just debating
telling me it's embarrassing but God
that's embarrassing come come out come
on come out of the the jizz closet 15.
that was 15 and uh you know doing the
deed and it accidentally got in my mouth
oh freaky yikes
that's rough man uh yeah it would uh was
not fun a lot of mouthwash a lot of
teeth dude you could have just your own
[ __ ] I mean I just said me too yeah it
happened to me too well um
we appreciate it yeah that's up to it
ABM come on it's never happened to you I
think that's [ __ ] I think everyone's
lying yeah I think something you guys
are lying you're too embarrassed it's
fine
what I'm lying about never getting it on
my own face yes
why do you think that that's such a
common occurrence because you're like oh
we got all my chest ones like I'm sorry
bro that's not a confession well
that's [ __ ] why are you gatekeeping
coming on faces
it's a real version
alert let's do a poll let's do a poll
have you ever accidentally or purposely
I guess about this have you ever [ __ ]
on your own faith before
yes or no just yes or no
you know yes or no
doesn't need to be
it can be accidental or on purpose
you can be honest it's anonymous
this is going to be really interesting
actually
come keeping someone said in the
comments come keeping stop come keeping
me dude
have you ever chizzed on your own face
this is Peak right here my friends this
okay so all right I'm gonna come we have
35 yes so
there's more one one in three men have
come on their own face that that is
still higher than I would have dude this
is women too I guess
wait well women I mean this question is
obvious that's weird
people are like cheating here this is
not um I think it's higher I think
people are still alive yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying it sounds like
what reason does anybody have to lie
love do you have you ever experienced
yeah it sounds like he has sounds like
love has yeah yeah yeah yeah love dude
I'm not trying to like associate with
this but [ __ ] it [ __ ] it yeah you loved
your own face Mr fikafika delete me from
this conversation he faked his own face
how we got onto this topic but let's
let's move on now thank you guys for
your honesty 32 and to the other 68
shame on you for lying you think you
think a hundred percent of men 100 come
on their own like I just wasn't really
trying to nut and I just nut how and why
I did I I don't know I just nutted I
just nutted where were you and what was
in your visual field
um Modern Family [ __ ] I mean we're lying
up all up and down this interview bro do
I look like I [ __ ] [ __ ] with some funny
[ __ ] like that I don't get down like
that bro no hell no I'm out bro hey
thanks for the interview
blue face baby what's up man hey I don't
know who this is but he reminds me [ __ ]
her right in the [ __ ] yeah Jeezy work
[ __ ] yeah Jeezy world coming soon I'm
about to go crazy man
no no no no no no hey I'm sober though
this is my personal sober
oh Jeezy is q
of Q Anon oh Jeezy is cute I honestly
don't I didn't know about that he's the
one who infiltrated the entire
government you gotta get flowers
yep keep that music down good call on
that
do you know G I don't know who these
guys are you know Jeezy yeah
go ahead my [ __ ] don't love me no more
all my favorite rappers are dead bro
long live X I never had no Role Models I
never had no Father Figure so I looked
up to bro I'm named after a [ __ ]
who wasn't even my Dad what's your name
my name is
[ __ ] my name and all I do is [ __ ]
shoot videos and [ __ ] Photoshop
pictures of [ __ ] for the cover
art y'all go home and call your parents
you say hi Mom hi Dad you wake up tell
your mom hi she [ __ ] gots breakfast
on the table waffles eggs all that me no
that's how you think that we live no I'm
not saying I'm saying it's possible
because me I've never experienced that
[ __ ] and it's never had breakfast no I'm
not saying I'm an orphan I'm not saying
I never had breakfast but I don't go
home to my parents and I haven't since I
was a [ __ ] baby because I ain't worth
nothing it's not true man I'm just worth
what I [ __ ] wear on my body but I
just want to tell you man you're not
worthless I don't give a [ __ ] my [ __ ]
State's full of Skittles and the baby
should have been here well what's your
name his state is full of Skittles what
does that mean
it's derogatory for homosexuals I
believe so
wait what would I [ __ ] wear on my
body I was feeling really bad for him
until he had to get homophobic
I still feel bad for him it's not his
fault so he's gay he's had a bad life
you know do you look for scapegoats
the man just needs a friend who's not
also who's like
I'm trying to tell you man you're not
worthless I don't give a [ __ ] my [ __ ]
State's full of Skittles and Skittles he
said I've never heard that phrase before
is that something people say Skittles
Taste the rainbow yeah right it makes
sense I've just never heard that before
bro is that a problem I mean you're with
a bunch of Mormons maybe it's Mormon I
know the Mormons don't like uh they do
not like the homosexuals the Mormons
actually spent like when California was
the first state I think one of the first
States if not the first to legalize uh
same-sex marriage and the Mormon Church
spent like
tens of millions of dollars to campaign
against it
I'm saying in this article that some
alt-right people are using terms like
Skittles to mean Muslims Skypes mean
Jews
Skypes yeah yeah they're using these
weird terms to cover I don't know what
the hell it's Waits Skittles means
Muslims in this article is what they're
saying but no that's I don't believe but
that's what that guy's referring to this
I see Skittles is slang for gay or part
of lgbtq that makes sense yeah
why you gotta hate on gay people bro
like I get your whole
I get your whole like
life is hard and [ __ ] but damn
what the gays do to you
and the baby should have been here well
what's your name Kelly binker Modern
Edge Kelly Baker
Custom Cabinets we got Modern Edge
custard cabinets so uh
how many times have you had your ass
eaten
I haven't this guy's very preoccupied
with homosexuals
Asian
Skittles that doesn't I mean
that's true eating half that's actually
true you're right you know I stand
corrected but I just think maybe this
guy needs to
yeah but I'm not against it so if XXX
tentacion came to you before his passing
and had a homegirl with him when he
performed in Salt Lake City Utah and he
had a homegirl here trying to lick your
booty hole what would you say yeah okay
I think this guy's really obsessed with
booty holes that's it he really is
potentially mine that's what I've
noticed
laughs
answer the question bro don't touch but
I mean who knows I have been to federal
prison so oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
we are cutting these okay there you go
[Music]
[ __ ] and alcohol that is yeah
there's something else in his box I
don't think
weed is really good I think he's on the
other side people that it's not legal
that [ __ ] really [ __ ] sucks [ __ ] at
least we got this
this is my daughter and she loves post
Malone what in God's name are you doing
there with your [ __ ]
that girl is so young dude oh my God
what the hell how do you feel about post
Malone
like he's really cool and stuff she
loves post Malone she's jamming them all
the time your mom's post Malone men are
doing impossible things
I'm on YouTube
[Music]
I don't know
[Music]
just bring the music down
oh post was there what the hell yes the
Latter-Day Saints bro why don't you like
Mormons I'm the Antichrist
[ __ ] the Mormons Bro [ __ ] religion [ __ ]
religion we're next to the Antichrist
I like dressing edgy bro goodbye yeah I
think that's about some sums it up
this is just young cringy people
honestly like I think we were all
probably had a little bit of a
cringe uh uh you know
I could have easily been one of these
guys monster many people just like this
yeah this is basically at like uh you
know 18 to 24 let's say I've been
drinking this since I was 12. but
because caffeine is my addiction what do
you want to be when you grow up famous
it's my [ __ ]
vaccinated and ready to [ __ ]
[ __ ] who anyone anyone everyone here
let's do it you want to [ __ ] everyone
here let's do it I don't give a [ __ ] yes
sir
I love that no not me remember these
faces sipping on Coco [ __ ] I go Loco
think that I'm playing [ __ ] that is a
No-No taking this [ __ ] see like what
addicted [ __ ] so good that little hoe
is a dick you sipping on lean I've been
sipping on Kool-Aid talking that [ __ ] in
the boy you're a munchkin they call me
Lil Jose and I'm here to get the pay
cause harm [ __ ] [ __ ] and I leave
them in the ditches and I stay real they
fly it's so embarrassing though
I used to I was rapping back then were
you when I was 21 not trying to be a
rapper I was just goofing around but
when you get drunk everyone freestyles
when they get drunk right yeah
let's hear what you got oh [ __ ] no dude
hey hey
big 14 on a b
come a [ __ ] [ __ ] imma get that for
free I love that imma come [ __ ] his
voice is cracking I'ma come [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so he's singing as Bar Mitzvah yeah
exactly
oh God
hey let him dream then
dare to dream
Utah rap Festival 2021
okay okay
dude you're like 13 bro yeah but that
hit a little bit it did hit though let's
go back it did kind of hit Olivia's
falling in love with uh no no audience
yeah
yo this kid slaps we gotta get we need
uh this kid plus Island boy club also
the first guy in this group not the
middle but the first guy was you thought
he slapped and I can't get behind that
I'll re-listen
I think this kid kind of slaps though
imma get that for free hey got that then
I snap back Rocky then Slappy stop it
and go stop [ __ ] in the Slime that a
rock with super toxic boxing like the
Oxys and you know we popping I'm talking
chicken they know I'm Robo can't talk
cause I'm in a throw bro Star Wars come
on solo drugsy dressing up Polo Iced Out
call me Frozen say I'm a driller walking
the party with all of my Killers run up
I stay in a villa Glock 945 it'll start
Kill Ya [ __ ] her appendix issue
dude you heard his voice crack
I mean at least wait till puberty bro
just wait for your your voice to do
drugs
call me Frozen rap on the skrilla say
I'm a driller walking a party with all
of my Killers running I stay in a villa
Glock 945 it'll start Kia [ __ ] her
appendix
you know what I don't think there's
anything wrong with this voice cracking
some of us oh come on
I got I got perfect grades in the sifts
always but one C my mom tried to beat me
she said you need straight A's would you
kidding me
bars I'm hitting it yo okay
my mom didn't give me lunch money so I
went to get pizza from Domino's for from
lunch period okay and brought my hose
brought it back security guard said
where you going can't believe campus so
I said with my Gap
yeah where are you going my mom tried to
ground beef
she could control me
bars thank you I'm ready for the Utah
rap Festival let's go
um I get straight A's but I got one C my
mom wasn't happy
[Music]
hmm
hey my uncle pays me a hundred dollars
per a so I get paid when I get to see it
really [ __ ] me up I count all that
money so I can get my Puffs oh you know
what's up fill that bag up I got a rich
Uncle he picked me to get straight A's
bars I got an oxy I took mad oxy with my
friends it was crazy
then I [ __ ] a [ __ ]
without a condom
bars
this is a fat meat is it Fire Pizza
anyone else want to go
ahead Olivia I heard you rap he wants to
rap about being in high school
or middle school maybe in his case
go ahead Olivia
fill that bag up I don't think I have
any ask the girl to do the dance with me
she said no so I beat her psych I don't
hit women I respect women okay let's get
them okay let's get it so I asked my
second choice she said yes it was dope
we kissed once held hands all night
what's up I'm a player I'm a pimp I hold
hands with girls then I get then I take
them to the movies
mom's car keys no how about some
Parmesan cheese looking like Jason
Voorhees up in here because I'm rolling
in really cool now shut up
yeah I like that though I'm cruising
with my mom's car keys I got the windows
down what's up my mom's got a pretty
nice car
it's like an Audi uh A2 not the bit not
the best one but midline it's enough to
to impress the [ __ ]
just I'm still a virgin working on that
I'm working on that
anyway
let's move on it's like getting dark I
feel like it's fine
are you [ __ ] serious
they canceled our order why they didn't
like our wrap I don't know shut up why
is this happening yeah how could this
happen to me
yo no explanation just straight dropped
dude this is the worst News man you had
to do manicino I'm just gonna say this
is karma for the Mutiny yeah the Mutiny
the Mutiny the Mexican food truck would
have never [ __ ] pulled that [ __ ] off
yes for sure
this is the worst you know what we do to
mutineers
short of eight people dying of at the oh
what
no I was just saying it's the worst
thing I was making it besides that joke
about killing them but then you
in there
what were you gonna say Dan
that we should execute the mutineers but
then you brought up the AstroWorld thing
right as I was doing this oh you're
about to make a death Joe yes no we
don't joke that's super inappropriate
shame on you
[Music]
though I'm devastated about the food so
are we gonna order more it's too late
isn't this video like an hour no it's
almost over let's let's let's just keep
going
Sam said she could order something else
I'm enjoying myself Chad's enjoying
himself I'm not this is this I'm ending
it after this I'm not going I'm not
doing a five hour show I have a kid and
[ __ ]
so we're gonna replace man I'm not
talking about a b
well if we order food we can play Smash
that's fine but I can't keep the podcast
going after this dude
let's finish it
bad little Barbie I'm her little king
that's little Barbie I'm her little kid
paying for tents then we pull up in
bands yes we pull up in bands and I stay
with my friends
that's all I got
a little plug there Legend
oh some of the stuff I rap about may not
be true but it's what everyone wants to
hear now people just want to hear
straight questions smoking here bro what
happened
was that your fog [ __ ]
because it feels like it's blowing for
this way which doesn't make sense
huh all right I gotta finish this video
I [ __ ] shoot people I straight you
smoke weed like it doesn't matter people
want to hear that [ __ ] I swear I pour my
heart my feels out into my music [ __ ]
I grew up with like an abusive mom
mentally physically and she kicked me
out the house for some dumb [ __ ] I used
to live in Ogden and then I moved all
the way down here with my father and me
and my father recently just got evicted
from our house and I was like out on the
street basically and then this has been
my friend for like six years and he told
me he was like hey bro like you really
need a place to stay like I got you you
like I got an extra room right now and
so I was like bro you're a lifesaver and
so now I've been living with him for a
few months what do you want to be when
you grow up bro that's sad
shout outs to him that's [ __ ] up I
want to be a famous rapper actually I'm
on my way there 300 000 views on two
songs
get there one day what how old are you
is she wearing a copy
Compton Utah I mean right Compton Utah
[Music]
that's their song
[ __ ] the haters [ __ ] what everybody has
to say it's that right mindset that gets
you there
what the [ __ ] another Banger from the
channel thugs what was the name of it
same with that brand
[Applause]
V long thugs baby
yeah that was a great video shouts out
all right that's it for the bonus part
we have been going for 10 hours I
believe
so thank you everyone for watching as
always we love our pooper Troopers yo we
love our food for Troopers
I I'm not doing this
it's too late in the day
thank you everybody thanks to our
members guys thank you thank you to
everyone the members mean everything to
us you know it makes a huge difference
on the channel
we're working on exclusive content for
y'all
and uh boy this was a long 20-hour
stream here today
but it was great
thank you to everybody we'll be back on
our usual episode
um
Wednesday for members Thursday for
everybody else off the rails
right yeah correct we're doing four
episodes this week
leftovers is back four episodes a week
four episodes a week where how many
episodes do you do [ __ ] zero that's
right
four episodes and one behind the scenes
we'll have five different pieces of
content God bless
wow wow what a hustle wow wow all right
guys well take care have a good week
we'll see you on Wednesday or Thursday
salute peace and love
[Music]
[Music]